thank you thank you gentlemen and GS
coming hey guys it is a brand new
podcast and for all you guys that say
that I keep saying it's a brand new
podcast yeah that's the way I feel about
it I feel like it's a brand new podcast
so that's why I say it it's a brand new
podcast it's a brand new podcast it is a
glorious day in my life I very very
happy Le do you want to grab that mic
and be a part of my intro
I'm in the man cave I'm having a
celebratory cigar because this afternoon
I just did
Conan yes you did thanks for affirming
that Leanne I was unsure it was great
yeah uh it was fantastic it was a blast
it was uh a career highlight I wrote
that I put it on all my social medias um
where I filmed the intro and it was um
for those of you who don't know Conan
was is has been one of my guilty
pleasures for a very very long time um I
would I
discovered the joy of Conan show with
nor McDonald maybe the best interview
ever done was have you ever seen it no
Norm McDonald and Courtney Thorne smith
and uh I guess in Norm's interview he
made fun of Carrot Top and Courtney
Thorn Smith came on and she was
promoting a movie called chairman of the
board and Norm didn't say anything the
whole interview and then Conan goes what
are you going to say about that hun Norm
how you going to make a joke about that
and he goes how do they spell it
chairman of the b r d oh God yeah
Leanne's not good when you run jokes by
her cuz sometimes she just goes yeah um
but yeah that was one of the funniest
things I've ever seen um and and all of
Norm's Conan appearances have been
amazing and
then adversely I got I got I became
obsessed with Conan and and at the same
time it was right I think probably right
when Bill Burr started doing Conan have
you ever seen Bill bur Conan's
appearances no oh they're amazing
they're amazing and so well what makes
them amazing what makes their
appearances on Conan any different than
anywhere else um I I can't say that that
Bill's uh panel appear I I I think
Conan's a little more apt to let you do
panel panel is when you sit on the couch
um but then and then you get guys like
Gary Goldman who go old school and go no
no no I'm really good at standup I want
to do standup or Jay Larson you ever see
Jay larsson's going in appearance no j
Jay larsson's con appearance
is I I would say probably the best
standup
set one of the best stand-up sets I've
seen on a night on a him and Gary
Goldman you've seen Gary Goldman's I
played it for Dad Dad and I listen to it
in the car and dad was [__] howling
laughing D Gary did one about the uh
abbreviations of the states yes I've
heard that it's really funny oh it's a
[__] amazing and J did one about
getting someone called his phone and it
was and they said it was the wrong
number and then he became a part of
their thing I'm sure I played that for
you I think so yeah um I know that uh uh
Cameron espositos it was is like one of
the like Conan just it's just the people
that work there have
allowed really great talent to do
exactly what they do that's a great
compliment and um and I and I will say
that um I don't think that my appearance
Compares at all to any of the ones I've
just mentioned but I will definitely say
that in my little career that I have
it's top of it's top of the block for me
like I loved it I absolutely loved it
and uh and I you know if JP's listening
and if anyone over at Conan's listening
thank you um but it was great it was
great you know it's like you have a
weird connection with those guys a long
time ago Conan uh and Andy RoR were
staying at the universal Sheridan when I
was where I was living when I was
working with Will Smith and I saw them
they were shooting in La for a week this
is I think when they must have been
based out of New York and these I'm
talking dimes were following them around
and you could see that they were like
they followed them into the hotel they
follow him to the bar the bar was in the
middle at the universal Sheron at the
time and I was sitting at the bar and I
was watching them thinking maybe I'll
bump into Conan and then
these girls tried to get into the
elevator with them and they were going
up to their room and Conan's he must
have said something so weird like hey gu
hey ladies look it's Mike Tyson and they
turned around
and the elevator door shut and before
they could before the girls could stop
he goes see you later gos oh my god
there was just I don't know so it's been
a
it's a person that I've been a big fan
of for a long time I got to do this TV
show so that's four minutes of a [__]
celebr celebration of a moment yeah um
you deserve it but thank you thank you
everyone that watched it I will be
posting um in short I told the machine
story um that story has gotten a second
life uh breathed into it from the
internet from my special um for all you
who watch my special thank you and I all
I ask is you know I keep posting the
machine story on on on on social media
that's part of this business so when I
do just share it again I it really means
a lot that I that I post it on Facebook
or Twitter and that you guys share it
like 15 159 times you've [__]
retweeted it really does mean a lot I am
doing dates in London everyone in London
I have not uh locked down a place we
have a couple places we're looking at
the question is I just don't know how
many tickets I'm going to sell and I
don't oh by the way there's the keys to
the [__] gate I know I took them out
of the okay okay thanks um sorry uh I am
in Buffalo this weekend I'm I I would I
would beg to say those shows are
probably going to be sold out so get
your tickets right away uh Lexington
next week you can probably get tickets
for those shows I can't imagine I'm
selling out in Lexington Comedy Off
Broadway but uh but I'll be there and
then Parlor Live and then I'm going to
London San Antonio uh I'm gonna do more
Texas dates we're switching around some
dates I think we're going to do I don't
know we're switching around some dates
so we're not locked into this machinist
tour machine machinist tour what do you
think I should call it I like The
Machinist n machine I like The Machinist
well the machine only because people
have just heard the story for the first
time there are literally 20 million
people that have just heard the story
for the first time so I feel like stay
with the brand in keep going yeah they
Mach but all the people that matter to
me are these people listen to the
podcast and they all listen to Rogan and
they were there they've heard a little
bit a little bit they're like week's
news they're a little bit like Bert
we've been with you for a long time what
do you think that all your fans call it
the Mickey manal Jee tour Call It The
Machinist tour call it that long strand
DNA tour the [__] that's brand new to us
is what we enjoy I'm a fan of podcast
just like you are if you got to remember
we are we are we are by the way we're a
significant number these days but we are
loyal we are die hard we will go see our
the guys we love no matter what if Joey
Diaz ever gets into Canada people will
with [__] felonies will break into
Canada just to go see Joey Diaz in
Canada all right this is a long [__]
intro and this is a long podcast because
it's a great [__] podcast
uh stop what you're doing right now and
download the laughable app the laughable
app is an app that I'm associated with
Ari shafir associated with and Greg fit
Simmons associated with we're also
reaching out to some other guys to be
associated with it uh it is a very great
app and this is why I'll tell you this
it's a podcasting app so you download
it and
uh you type in your guy let's just say
Joey Diaz we all love Joey on podcast
immediately it's going to show you the
Church of What's happening in right now
uh the Church of What's Happening Now in
the top of his list but then it will
show you every podcast he's ever been on
let's do Theo Von Theo Von Owen Benjamin
Shane Moss guys that are great [__]
podcast guests you it'll show you their
podcast and you can find all the
episodes they've done but then it'll
show you all the other ones they've done
that's what makes this app so great is
it Aggregates all the good [__] you like
for you I am not talking about this
podcast app for any other reason than I
like what they do they pitched it to me
and I liked it and and I've hung out
with them and they're making changes to
accommodate what what we as podcast fans
don't like and so if you have a note hit
them up on Twitter tell them hey man
make that [__] for the Android I'm
losing my wife you're falling asleep
aren't you no no no I'm listening and so
check out laughable uh go to go to the
App Store Ty download at laughable and
you're going to [__] dig it and then
just put download your podcast from
there um who gives really cool it's a
really great app I'm I'm being dead
serious when i say this um hopefully we
can get something out of Dollar Shave
Cub coming up soon because tomorrow I'm
shaving clean and then doing Kelsey
Cooks podcast or web series where
comedians put makeup on comedians but
I'm bringing my daughters and I think my
daughters are going to put makeup on me
and her and try to make us look like
celebrities oo la la yeah um my wife is
definitely falling asleep why I can see
it I know when you do this you just do
this thing where you're like I did not
just disinterested no I'm not
disinterested um so yeah so that's it um
always check out all things comedy this
is a real Joy this podcast for me
because as you know I've talked about
these guys on probably my last three
podcasts
um
I I don't I don't know what to um I I
don't know what to I look I've brought
them up a number of times on my podcast
um recently I'm stuttering right now uh
Dave Anthony is uh one of the uh people
at all things comedy which is me Al Bill
Ari Tommy buns it's all our podcasts all
our I'm just saying the guys I can think
of but Dave Anthony is one of the guys
he's one of the heads of the company uh
and he's a fantastic guy he's written on
Marin he's good friend with Marin he's
just a fantastic podcaster he's been in
this game for a long time he's had the
game he had the podcast walking in the
room with Greg Barron who's fantastic
and we talk about Greg on this podcast
um and Gareth Reynolds is his partner in
this podcast Gareth Reynolds was on
Travel Channel for a second and so I had
a connection with there but they both of
them have also worked with Sam tripley
on the naughty show I do this backup
information for those of you who don't
know and you go Bert remember to explain
who they are before sometimes you just
get into the podcast we don't know who
the [__] we're talking to well it's also
the it's incumbent on you to like Google
these people but this is who it is
Gareth Reynolds Dave Anthony Anthony
they have a podcast called the dollop
the dollop is [__] fantastic and I
was late to the game I saw it on the top
of the charts every week and then one
day I went I got to check this out and I
ran into Dave in an all things comedy
meeting and we got one tomorrow night
and we'll be there I'll see Dave
tomorrow night so hit up Dave and let
him know the machine sent you and that
you love this podcast this is the
podcast Dave recommended to me it's
called the rube it is so [__] good
what Dave does is he describes
historical events to Gareth who is
completely oblivious of anything
historical and Gareth shits on it
destroys it takes it apart questions it
Dave explains it Dave shits on it Dave
tears it apart they both commiserate on
it and it is so [__] funny it's
called the dollop the d o l l o p it's
with Gareth Reynolds and Dave Anthony
and they are my guests I hope you enjoy
their podcast as much you as you enjoy
this one because this one my friends is
[__] seamless you are going to come
in your pants it is that good of a
podcast what are you shaking your head
at Leanne never come in your pants no
not recently well wait till you hear
this podcast ladies and gentlemen
birdcast
27 Dave Anthony Gareth Reynolds the
dollop in the man
cave this is
the hello
are you serious yeah he to sell all here
grab grab
that um really
[Music]
yeah hilarious everyone talk real quick
hi yes hello perfect I did uh a podcast
with
um uh Tom Papa today and I I was like he
was using an H4
h4n yeah to do it and he didn't have
enough mics so they were going to share
I put in the H6 I pull my rig out and I
start rigging his [__] and I think I
didn't record audio on One
mic I come in arrogant as [__] I totally
[__]
up and I was he was like email that to
me when you get a chance I was like sure
sure yeah absolutely get that right to
you yeah I had also I'm dying I should
point out that I'm actually dying so I
did uh I did one with sigura in the car
and uh today and yesterday and I
listened to one of the tracks and I was
like and it was no audio from Sakura oh
[__] and I was like
[__] and then I went and I had I
had apparently I had stopped in the
middle of it and started recording again
on accident and then picked up audio
from him I really wish I really wish I
had someone to do you guys do yours by
yourself yeah just totally by yourself
yeah yeah do you even put in do you even
put in headsets or anything sometimes at
the start yeah yeah not not as much as I
should it's uh you know I've been
promoting your podcast on my podcast the
last three appreci I did it again when I
posted today I talked about it thank you
it was uh it's such a great podcast oh
thanks it really is the the rube I was
like I mean he's my favorite character
of all in the history of the world he
might be the be you know I ended up
getting into a spiral about
him I I'm obsessed yeah yeah he's it's
crazy so wait wait real quick so if
anyone doesn't know uh what is so the
name of your podcast is the dollop but
the the sto and and you basically tell a
historical fact to Gareth or historical
story and then you and you and it's just
such a great [__] podcast but real
quick who is the rubbe if you could like
pitch it okay so the rub was gu
ironically pitch it David ironically
pitch it so the rub was a guy who uh
played baseball around 1900 pitcher he's
a pitcher uh maybe the best pitcher of
the time but he pitched against Sai
Young uh and he was dumb as a [__]
box of rocks that's an
understatement that's a [__] like and
I I'm this is not going to do it justice
you have to listen to this podcast that
is a [__]
understatement yeah well not only dumb
but like insane like insanely dumb and a
combination always raging alcoholic
alcoholic uh obsessed with fire trucks
obsessed with fire trucks yeah he would
run off the mound and chase them in the
middle of games if you heard a firet
truck he would leave the mound and Chase
it like if you had a dalmati on your
team yeah and if people if people
realize he was stupid and they would
hold up like puppies in the stands and
he would run over to them yeah
like just he disappears one time and no
one knows where he is and they find a
wrestling alligators in Florida like by
the way I felt such a connection to this
guy I was like in the early 19th turn of
the century you that could have been me
yeah hardcore to this day you could
almost probably simplify Me In terms
like that yeah van beer and Wilder good
God yeah it is it and that and that just
and the podcast is you for like an hour
and a half hour and 15 minutes telling
the story and Gareth hearing it
commenting on it and you guys and I've
never heard it like so he just prepares
a story and I don't know what it's going
to be and we did we did a thing at all
things comedy and I was like and I
noticed your podcast is like all top
five podcasts in the in the in the world
I think always not not now it was for a
little while what was that what was like
I was like we got a like I got up there
too and I was like why why did that just
happen that's what's so strange is like
actually knowing the metrics of it is
such a bizarre nebulous thing in a way
yeah like cuz there's some days where
you I mean there's you know you could
like you could brag at any time like I
have the number one podcast today but
like that's or with albums people like I
have the number one album but it's like
you have at that moment you're selling
the most but you know it was very weird
we were the number one podcast in the
country that was like of all podcasts I
was like what's happening well because
then they give you a silver record to
put on the wall I don't know and it is
ties the studio together I bet you got a
big bump when you went on Rogan uh yeah
we were I that was a great episode those
man it was the best podcasting well that
podcast is
so uh I mean it's just so interesting
like it's always so interesting you know
what I I I was I if you said to me how
many times have you done Rogan I'd
probably say five it turns out I've done
like 20 times I no recollection of them
though because you go in Joe and like
whenever I'm there Joe's always in like
a giddy mood it's not like scientist
mood so he's like let's get high let's
get drunk let's get [__] up let's
gigle I mean we did one that was 5 hours
long one day and it and I didn't piss
once and I didn't and when we got we
were like you want to play pool for an
hour like it was and you both pissed
your pants oh dude the one I the ones I
did with sigura those last two ones were
like probably the best thing I've ever
been a part of really the because of the
competition you your competition with
him is so
engaging we had uh it's you know some
kid came up to me the other day and he
was like uh like it's really cool that
you guys are really friends I go it's
just I mean like we're all friends like
we all hang out like everyone knows each
other but he's like no I'm like blown
away is this part of your bit that you
guys you guys really friends or is this
like a so hard to believe I go that's
why podcasting is [__] good because
it's not produced it's not can I tell
you a little sidebar to the story yeah
do you I first heard of you probably
seven years ago I was we have this weird
connection I walked in to Travel Channel
and Fred Fred uh gra uh Graver Fred
Graver was like uh by the way he starts
ation off with uh we just found the
funniest comedians in the business and
I'm like okay well awesome Fred thank
you so much you're too sweet Fred I'm
glad you're aboard yeah really awesome
see that poster behind you and uh and it
was Manan yeah and I remember watching
that and going God damn it that's the
show I want to do instead I'm riding
roller coasters well it was such a great
[__] show yeah we were caught in a
very that's a show that I did with uh my
buddy Evan man and it was insane to do
like as I'm sure you know like you know
just traveling like and doing these
having these experiences and just sort
of getting like the cliff notes of it
and going doing all this crazy [__] but
we like went to space camp we went to
ninja camp we did a Civil War
reenactment we did this whole season of
the show and then as it would be and and
throughout that process were being sort
of told what you heard about us about
you it was like you know this is the
model like we would get you know
episodes of your show you realize they
hated my show
but but but okay but okay so we had
hated but you but your show was on for a
while they loved our show but then right
when we were putting the finishing
touches on it well what they did was
they aired some of they aired two in a
night the night of the NBA playoffs and
and they left an hour in between about a
sand castle show so they two new
episodes by the way I worked with those
sand castle people I had to do I had to
do an integration with them and we met
the sand castle people the people bu
people who make giant sand castles I
tell you I would argue maybe possibly
the most boring thing in the world is
watching someone make a sand you [__]
kidding me that sounds awesome just a
guy putting sand in his shapes how that
every channel now that I hear a fact I'm
doing I'm trying to I'm pitching one
about guys who make dirt uh castles oh
yeah dirt Builders that's going to be
amazing and I like that it's 2 hours
long I think it has to be real it has to
be it's real time dirt building an
18-hour Real Time marathon of dirt
Builders let me tell you something if
they didn't incorporate the function of
time lapse
into I mean it's already garbage it was
such a what happens at the end of it
what well you see the Sand Castle come
on it's a reveal it's yeah yeah it's
hard to do the teaser coming up well you
got to see it obviously it was can but
can I tell you we did a we did an
integration with them where they I did
one of my shows and I worked the and it
was so much
fun and I was like I was like this is
one of the funnest things I've ever done
they taught us how to make a real sand
castle and I was like like oh this is in
my head I was like this is functional
information I'm going to blow my kids
away yeah it was actually really fun um
but yeah that I that as a as a as a an
experience to watch is uh I remember
that time there's only so much you can
do so vividly yeah well then so they did
that and then they were like we're going
to put it back on in the fall and then
the fall came two episodes and then how
long in how long months months so two
episodes not even back to back sand
castle in between Castle sandwich yes
and then months and then like let's you
know what this needs this needs this is
so hot that we need to take a break for
months it's a programming style not
enough networks are embracing right I'll
tell you right now Air 2 leaves 6 months
air none it's it's beautiful oh I've
I've uh I could I can I've had so many
shows on that Network I can up that and
say we did one where they aired it
didn't like the number so they started
airing it at 700 a.m. on Saturdays my
but mine never aired that's the best
time they never fully aired it they
aired those two and then the rest aired
so they literally shot a season of the
show and then they were like no like
it's a home movie what's the [__]
point of that you have it made throw it
up think of trying to explain this to my
English mother she was like your mom's
from England yeah just I was like but
it's not airing what what you but you've
made it I was like look Hollywood's got
a big dick and sometimes it puts it in
you you know what happened huh I bet the
sand castle people complained all the
all the fans of sand castling were like
what is this [__] don't even get if that
is are there people uh no but that is
that was a that was a tool in and this
time in television that was a tool to
get your show back on the air is go onto
your Facebook page and start a protest
and there would be that work I it didn't
happen to my show but I remember it
happened to someone's show where it got
cancelled not mine and then they all
fought for it and they're like [__] it
we'll bring it back oh yeah uh yeah
angel had that or some show like that
and that where fans were so rabid they
were at C CS at CBS was like [__] it
let's do it all right hard to park I can
tell you all the behind the scenes about
your show if you like I know everything
yes because I was I was lovely so at the
time Adam and I had the Adam uh Richmond
and I had the two highest rated shows on
the network Y and they were not a fan of
mine um and they didn't like my digital
footprint they were like your digital
footprint leaves something to be desired
what is that it's when you Google B the
first thing that came up was as wax next
thing that came up was uh PCP with Tracy
Morgan like it was like just everything
that Googled me so they're like they're
like we need to scrub your digital
footprint so they just pulled me off and
I think in all honesty I think Fred and
Loren were was the president at the time
Fred had really great intentions of
bringing really talented people on the
network and making really cool shows
everyone that Fred brought in and I'm
not I mean I have no there's I can gain
nothing from Fred anymore in my life he
works at Twitter yeah but and he was a
great guy he did not like me TW he get
you a
Twitter show no he can get definitely
get your numbers up on Periscope thank
you fredk so verify me Fred yeah so but
he had really good intentions but I
think he was taking really big swings at
a company that that brand-wise wasn't
ready to make that kind of stuff I mean
Steve ranella and you yeah uh Steve
Rella now is possibly one of the most
recognizable hunters in the world one of
Joe Rogan's best friends yeah and yeah
and and uh and it was it was a really
interesting time but Adam and I had the
number one shows and then you guys came
out and I think they were like comedy
doesn't comedy doesn't work for our
Network oh my God that really is what I
mean that is basically you know what it
felt like because which which network is
this TR Travel Channel so we we' done it
and then it's almost like the you know
it happens all the time it really
happens in marketing here too when a
brand is like we really want to push the
limits and then by the end of the
process it's as vanilla and [__] as
everything else because they get scared
and that is basically
you know rather than air it ever they
were like this is not our brand and we
just you know they just don't it and you
know and I'll say that and I'm certain
this is getting to travel channel if
we're talking about it but and I will
say one of the things that I really that
really I know it bums them out as
well oh wow were you recording uh no no
Sean Evans from hot ones is calling me
got gossip can't take it cuz I know want
to talk about have you guys done hot
ones now oh have you seen it yes oh [__]
seen but one of the things that I think
that that network does exclusively that
I'm not I've never been I've never been
uh a victim of but I do think that it
would benefit them to to air a whole
season of stuff and I and I'm sure they
have a reason that they don't they don't
they they don't do it kill it they put
it up if it gets numbers they stick with
it well that's not how it works
especially now now especially now but
but from what I from what I'm hearing is
you guys killed comedy on the Travel
Channel yes uh the two definitely had a
part of that yeah I
don't I think this might be Spartacus uh
yeah I'm definitely am the reason they
got more serious programming but they
but they were also like they're like
you're saying like your show and man
versus food were like they would succeed
and yet they were like it's not us like
there is that craving to like Define
yourself with something that you like
too and it's like just go with what
works and take [__] chances yeah take
CH it's you know and I say this I I'll
play Devil's Advocate right now but like
there is I've taken chances on this
podcast like where I go this would be a
good episode and it just doesn't pay off
because the fans are like hey man I
don't give a [__] about your wife right
like you talked to your wife and they
didn't like it uh like no but I know my
downloads and I know and I know people
just didn't tune in they're like no no
offense when's uh when's Burr coming on
yeah you know that's like onari and
Steve Raz easy coming on and so like and
but they would just air things and if it
didn't like the scar Brothers had a a
pilot over there uhhuh and they aired an
episode and and I guess I and it just
didn't rate and so and you know the
other thing is th that that Network
really succeeds with you know [__]
they've already got stuff in the can of
like Andrew Zimmer that rates through
the roof every time they put it up I
mean man versus food was getting ratings
higher than anything yeah that show is
huge yeah Adam is just and you know some
of those guys I'm not I sometimes I feel
like I'm not set up for that stpe that
type of Television even though I did it
for so long but like Adam is such an
amazing [__] host I swear to God
right now I could call him on the phone
and go give me your read for Columbus
and he could rattle it off yeah
classically trained actor right yeah he
is yeah like the whole the whole thing
that he ended up like eating all the
like at I mean I forget where he went
but he went to like a prestigious place
and he went to Yale and he got and he
was like a classically trained actor and
then he was like look at that meat
inside that [__] you know yeah
so it's like yeah but and there was I
think he was probably he's he might be
one of the like there we were talking
about this earlier with Marin and Rogan
are two of the smartest people I've ever
been around they say things very cutting
very very intelligent very uh insightful
like I always say this about Rogan every
time I have a conversation with him
every opinion he has he's thought about
for a day yeah like I don't I'm I'm such
a [__] [__] oh I blurt [__] out
constantly yeah it's my that is very
true it's like he I mean he really know
like he knows he knows everything Adam
Richmond knows something about
everything that's crazy one of those
guys and really I mean we met him
briefly but he was super nice I mean
just really really nice D [__] world
like the sweetest guy but uh but yeah I
was I was there for that whole thing
yeah what it was a dream
they they wanted Fred wanted that to
succeed so bad I think he was caught in
between Loren and the company and the
company was like you know their whole
their whole message with that Network's
been information it's so funny as Comics
were like [__] information put
interesting up there but as a fan of
watching Travel Channel I've always been
a fan the information is what drives our
show had zero information yeah like it's
the thing about your podcast that is
fascinating is like I'm laughing but
when I stop laughing you come back in
with more information then another L
like the information drives your podcast
and they always wanted that at the
network information first and I was I'm
not that guy very information is that's
a [__] whole like researching that's
a lot of goddamn work to get like proper
information and put it into a story like
especially for like a 22-minute show
that's not that's that's tough well but
also on the dollop the amount of things
you peel out are just insane that is
true I couldn't do your
Dave's job is I mean we when we go on
the road like I'll be I'll just come
what you live show do live shows yeah
yeah you want you want are you around
love and I am the most uninformed person
in the world hey I'll comp at you on the
podcast I us think Helen Keller and an
Frank with the same person yeah if
you're if you're around on February 6
we're doing a live one that's a much
different experience for Anne Keller
what what uh wait February 6th yeah um
oh [__] I was supposed to tickets up for
sale today I forgot yeah I'm around
February 6th
wait oh wait I have what time uh 9: yeah
I'm around okay let's do it done
um wait how did you guys meet just okay
so he used to do a podcast with Sam
tripley I was on uh triple's podcast
yeah yes it was like the third wheel the
naughty show second wheel I joined it
late like he I mean uh yeah I mean I was
definitely like the third yeah third or
second wheel spare tire I don't know
what's the automobile what the hell kind
of vehicle are we talking
about the Third Wheel third wheel on
what one of those weird motorbikes with
three wheels I'm the back one all right
I'm near the I'm the side car um but
yeah we met uh we met there and then um
I would I would go on there and just to
bust Sam's balls like I would just sit
there and make fun of the podcast while
I was on it cuz he always had like
[__] strippers on and [__] and I'd be
like it's a podcast why am I looking at
this girl's [__] right now cuz Tri
[__] brains in the gutter constantly
literally I'm looking at a girl's
[__] like she's bent over spreading
her ass and I'm like it's a podcast but
it it like but triple like what I love
about Sam tripy and I love I mean I
really genuinely love the dude is that
he is he is Unapologetic for what he
wants and his show was what he wanted it
was what he was into and I enjoyed
sitting there going Watching Sam
experience you know what he what he
thrived I still think Sam and big J Oak
and shour together totally CU they're
the same very different acts very
different acts same demographic totally
but Sam tripley when I so little sidebar
to this uh I move out to LA I want to
talk about New York but I move out to LA
I do the first thing I do is uh National
Lampoons funny people it's uh Frank
kando is hosting it when he's on hype no
maybe he was on Mt TV okay no he might
have been on hype do you remember hype
no do you remember chicken no chicken
wait the comic chicken do you remember
him yeah
oh yeah who was chicken who was chicken
chicken chicken uh chicken came let's
just say chicken came out from out of
nowhere okay by the way so did the egg
if Comedy Central if Comedy Central did
a [__] a documentary about this guy
oh God I would
literally so the hell you should well
now I can't know about
chicken but I'll tell you he he just he
just so Mont it was when Montreal when
you could go up there and get
19998 so you could go up to Montreal and
just land a [__] huge deal in new
your whole your life was changed so the
story is I want to do up you this with
him with you so this is a time when when
uh Mitch Hedberg did a show did a new
faces show destroyed got offered like a
a a six-figure deal like
$800,000 and Dave Becky grabbed him put
him on a plane and flew him home and
said no don't speak to anyone ever again
and Mitch is like what he's like the
only thing you can do is [__] this up
leave and this is a different [__]
day I mean I it this is when Dave Becky
got Sue Costello a [__] deal off of a
five minute tape wow [__] VHS hold on
I got a deal I got a deal that that
picture that we were just talking about
Schaefer I was working the door at the
Boston Comedy Club Time Out New York
wrot an article about me because I was
just letting in college kids to drink
for free at the Boston Comedy Club I was
work the
door uh David tman came out and saw me
do standup he was working for Will Smith
I was at the door all I had was seven
[__] minutes and I got a sixf fig
deal working the
door working the [__] door holy [__]
I mean this is like this does not exist
and in hey I'm not working the door
tonight anymore you know what's crazy
I'm good on the door Barry cats made me
keep working the door course he did like
it's good for the store the door guy the
door story and then he just door on
stage he just loves saying I'm I got so
much stuff going on my door guys's got a
deal see from his end it makes sense
then he don't stop working the door bird
I got [__] I got six figures in the B
and I'm still doing 25 bucks a night and
bringing in 20 people so I can get my
spot hey how about give me a spot that
flyer is blown up I used to have to hand
that out I used to have to hand that out
I stacks of them and I had to hand them
out everywhere and Louis schaer was on
the center but to go back to
chicken
so that is the time Montreal so Frank
cendo gets a deal yeah from uh from a
tape he had and a tape he just did like
John Madden uhhuh Chris Farley and
Kramer uhhuh he gets a six fig deal from
the WB right chicken you remember George
Gallow
no he's this kid he just did crazy
noises like it was like it was like
watching the Tasmanian devil try to talk
and he got like a six- figure deal and I
was like what in the [__] is happening
how come I'm not getting a deal you're
too angry [__]
off have you tried making noises maybe
maybe make a fax machine noise and see
what
happens no I don't like it and and and
and and and then chicken goes to
Montreal yeah chicken and then chicken
goes to name was chicken just chicken
his real name is Michael roof okay by
the way I'm obsessed with this guy okay
like I'm being serious there is a part
of my ID whatever I don't even know if
that's the right thing that I just said
but there's a part of me that is
connected to this guy for the rest of my
[__] life well he well he he hit so
hard that it was like even with all
these deals what was his thing D well I
mean he [__] a stool to by the way
that is a compliment about his act I'm
not I'm not I'm not trying to be shitty
that is a compliment like so wait
chicken chicken [__] stools to music
right was it to music he was set no no
no it was to the the uh music from
Titanic right oh my God this plot is
play Titanic and [__] a stool and then
lean on it like and by the way I am
telling you when I say this it may sound
like we're [__] on him I have a
sincere connection as human being we're
just being honest yeah and he okay would
pose like Le decaprio on Titanic and
there was nothing really of substance to
his act no I think he could be almost
the opposite of substance like there was
nothing it and and was their setup to
stool Titanic bangs [__] I don't
remember I doubt it I want to say like
he was very it was very high energy so
it was a lot of like crazy high energy
okay like it's good looking guy he's
young uh full head of hair uh kind of
like a not not I wouldn't say like
ripped but doughy ripped you know okay
yeah yeah uh and just super high energy
I watched him at the Laugh Factory one
night with uh Reno klier and Reno klier
and him are really good friends and and
everyone came out to watch him and I sat
in the back and the place went [__]
bananas and I sat in the back and I was
like what is happening I was like I'm
blown away like I cannot figure out why
this is working right so he gets oh no
you no you would watch it you'd be like
I don't know what's happening but the
audience is going Mur the AUD audience
loved it have no idea you're like what
is what is going on right now right is
there a puzzle I don't understand did
chicken pay you and oh and then and then
uh he he him and Frank had both deals at
WB and it turned into his deal was
chicken's deal was like hug massive like
the biggest deal ever out ofre $100,000
or something crazy just under a million
maybe it was a million might have been a
million dollar deal it might have been
so much so that he like he took care of
his family with it like he he lived in
[__] up the C Fe no grew up in Florida
Florida in uh in in I wish I could
remember the name but it was right
outside Tampa right outside Orlando like
one of those weird Town sure like a
Carney Town yeah like bravard or yeah
right where Lobster Boy lives like like
that yeah we did an episode on Lobster
boy yeah
oh that's my neck of the
woods so uh we used to drive through
that town oh man he beat up his wife he
did a lot of [__] fasinating the story
of lobster boys so he comes out to New
York he gets hype hype is the show they
it's a sketch show it's going to compete
with Mad TV yeah because they were
supposed to do a show based on him but
then the more they got into it they're
like oh [__] he can't we can't get the
Titanic song he can't be the
focus it turns out he just [__] stools
there's actually not a lot there so they
couldn't the network was like What if
it's a chair and he's like I can't work
like this with all these
notes you're ruining the vision of
chicken this is going to get sad in a
second so oh no okay okay I'm sorry so
they ended up doing an ensemble with
chicken in it so that's a sketch show
called hype okay and and he's he's like
one of six or whatever I think Canda
would even say hype was a rough tough
show to sit through okay wasn't the best
sketch show yeah um I think it got
canceled after like six episodes real
quick yeah and then FR moves over to uh
Mad TV and chicken uh ends up booking uh
Black Hawk Down okay uh he ends up
booking um triple XX okay with Vin
Diesel a sidekick he ends up doing a
show on Spike uh called uh raising the
roofs where his family who's all very
redneck moves out to LA okay and he does
stuff like go to Red Carpet Events with
his uncle and his dad and school and and
they're big drinkers right and then uh
and then chicken decides to start doing
the road again yeah but I don't think he
ever ever did the road I don't think he
ever did the road and I don't think he
ever had the chops for the road and I
don't think he ever had the the passion
obviously for comedy the way that maybe
someone else would have right but
someone was probably like hey you can
make a lot of money on the road yeah get
out there and then he killed himself he
killed himself [__] yeah that's why we
said it would get sad oh [__] cuz the
road is not cool wow the road a bummer
the road really sucks no it does but
that's still like it really like how
long how how I mean it was just the
grind of that just got to him the whole
thing was this whole [__] Journey was
pretty quick man really it wasn't that
long it yeah it was four years maybe you
know and at that time I think a lot of
us you know the the business changed so
drastically from when I got my first
deal to like when I got to travel
channel that that like I was lost like
everyone was lost at that time and then
and I think chicken just didn't he
didn't have like a a a foundation yeah
you know Patrice O'Neil said to me um
one time he's like I when I got my my
second deal I got a deal right after
that again with CBS and Patrice goes I
feel sad for you and I was like what and
I was like only [__] Patrice could
take right a congratul congratulatory
moment and [__] you up with it and he's
like you got no Foundation he's like you
got no you you don't know comedy you
don't know the road you don't have any
way to make money other than television
and he's like I don't I can't make a ton
of money but I can definitely support
myself in doing comedy he's like you
should focus on getting to that place so
that when they knock you off the tower
you don't fall that far and I was like I
remember thinking like yeah that would
be cool and then when I all my TV shows
went away I definitely was like oh [__]
I got to start from scratch yeah and I
think chicken didn't have that
opportunity and when he got on the road
it was like it was like what
right he he's the best example
of of when you hit young and you're not
ready ah it's [__] brutal dude that
is that is the greatest [__]
statement of like
like being ready there's no better
feeling than to get a call go hey we we
want you to do April foolishness or
whatever and then going I could do that
easily like I have I have I've done two
specials I have like as opposed to being
like 23 and being like [__] I didn't I
didn't get [__] until Marin way [__]
late in life I got I had no nothing like
I'm almost 50 you are not yeah are you
serious you do not look 50 hey baby
don't wink at him Dave that's what
happens your over if you say say you
don't look 50 there's a sexual thing
happening there's [__] something sexy
how old you 37 oh I [__] pay money to
be 37 again I mean 37 I could [__]
run this business really dude with what
I know now yeah I mean 37 I was so lost
oh I was a [__] mess at 37 I had no
idea what was going on that no con but
doesn't that happen every like don't you
always think that that's what's such a
[__] about like aging is is that you
always look back 5 years ago and you
think I thought I was old then now I'm
old and I wasn't then and then in five
more years you go no cuz when you get
into your 40s it stops because you you
really start to realize what you can
build on and then it's leading somewhere
and then you're putting bricks in a
place and you're creating something well
you're when you're I didn't know that
when I was in my 30s when I was I was
still trying to grab [__] and make [__]
[__] happen at 37 I was like I need
to be on TV yeah that was it I was like
I need to be on TV like a [__] idiot
I should have I should have just been
like like I look at you right now like I
know for a fact that you will no doubt
be one of the most successful people I
know because you're you're 37 dude I
like I'm 44 we're at the exact same
place in our life I'm 44 and I go and I
go it's just like I I feel like I know
you I know you probably feel like this
too I know Marin feels like this
probably but like I go how much more
time do are people interested in me oh
totally God like at what point do I
become the what time at what point am I
the depressing guy at the FY house doing
the show where they're like hey man have
you taking your blood pressure medicine
like I think so but I don't remember God
doing the same bits back to back oh God
oh my you take I've done that a lot you
you take off your shirt and just a girl
in the front row just like silently
starts crying oh I had this moment I had
this moment where uh I do I did the
goddamn Comedy Jam and I I was in a band
with cre with a with a guitarist kicked
toal for the band cre and then I and
Scott sta Sayang With Me Now by the way
okay he comes up it's a spoiler alert I
shouldn't be talking about it I don't
give a [__] Creed we get it and so it's
your banned Scott st's like hey man we
you should uh maybe I'll sing like the
first chunk and then you'll come in
after that because I was supposed to
lead it off like I think artistically
it's probably better if I start it off
then you come in I was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh my God so these things
that destroys his of course he does I
come in oh God and I start the F my
lyric and I hear a girl in the front row
go
o audibly audibly go o it was so it's
tough to it's tough to maintain the
course mentally and not be at all like
all right because even as a comic You're
vulnerable when you're singing you like
if a joke go shitty if a joke go shitty
you're so much more
yeah it's like you're try you're
exposing yourself into hero oh and I and
I and I was like oh that's why Scott
wanted to start it off cuz he's like
don't [__] my song up totally like let's
start somewhere and then get to where we
are yeah yeah but but if he so so no one
knew so if he'd come out second would
have no one have known that he was going
to come out no so I I I mean total
spoiler alert the whole point of this
thing was that I mean technically Mark
trani doesn't remember me at all he has
no recollection of me so I brought out
my guitarist from our band that we were
in a college from Orlando John daker and
he comes out and I go this is my I'm
putting my band back together this is my
guitarist and then I bring in another
guitarist which happens to be Scott st's
guitarist they don't know that but he
played with Guns and Roses he comes out
and then I go you know the whole point
of the speech of my speech is that I'm a
I was a front man I wasn't a lead singer
I was a front man very different energy
sexuality and I was like X Factor yeah X
Factor X I [__] wish I had you
writing for this xor it's the xfactor
yeah and uh and I go what this band
could really use as a lead singer
someone who can remember the lyrics so
who doesn't L their voice and I bring
out Scott staff and and then I go we're
singing the greatest rock anthem of my
generation higher and we start saying it
and it I'll be really honest man not
only will I say this Scott sta forever
will go down in my book is the coolest
Rockstar I've ever met but I was moved
to like really to teach years I'll start
crying by talking about it now it was
such a great [__] moment to sing that
song with in my life that I said I've
said my daughters came to see it and I
said girls you just witnessed the my
favorite thing I've ever done on stage
it was so [__] fun that at the end
and at the end the whole [__]
audience is chanting Bert Bert I'm
[__] stomping around going yes yes
yes it was the greatest [__] it was
like that is great though I mean cuz
like that's one of those things too
where you know you get those moments and
you really are like man it's a really
amazing thing that I'm here and even I
mean on that level that's like insane to
be able to sing the song with the guy
and have your name chanted at the end of
that [__] yeah I know right yeah uh it
was yeah there i' I think I I've said to
someone we did a reading with oh you
guys should do Dr trw's podcast oh yeah
oh oh yeah definitely yeah Dr Dre and
Bob forer oh I love Dr Drew I love he
was on Marin we had him on marin oh you
did yeah hey did you ever get I sent you
an email a long time ago that you never
replied to
and always thought I always I always
thought it upset you uh I doubt it I'm
certain of it it said [__] you Dave
Anthony Bert no it was it was me you
Burr Ari and Tommy okay on the podcast
and Al and it was about someone joining
all things comedy yeah and then you
replied definitely we should have this
guy he's the funniest guy I know and
then I replied hold up a second Dave we
haven't really hung out yet you should
hang out with me before you say
that you just didn't rep you
just sure that made me laugh dude that
didn't make that's hilarious no reply
and I
went May you're the girl in the front
row no way that's there's no way that
did make me laugh that's [__]
hilarious and I was like and I was like
and then and then like I ended up
like listening to a podcast where where
maram was talking about you and I was
like and I was and he was like talking
about you in a way where I was like that
was the wrong joke to make I was like
[__] why am I such an idiot you
stupid b you're stupid Scot J and Boogie
Night [__] idiot [__] idiot I'll
change it if you don't like it and then
you just try to kiss him oh God oh my
God okay so I'm the king of making
people feel awkward like I [__] love
it my wife my wife is always just like
like when I when I texted him coming
over here I said uh cuz it was Wes was
doing the thing cuz I was late Wes was
doing the thing where the numbers are
going up slowly and you're just sitting
there like this is just terrible this is
oh you're watching the number like
watching the number minutes we found the
worst way for you to go and I text Dave
and he just goes yeah that happens at
the commuting hour I was
like anyway sorry your wife and then my
wife's always just like how are you like
cuz someone will say something and then
I just let them hang and I just stare at
them and she's like how do you do that
I'm like I just [__] love living in
that moment where people don't know what
to do you're just like look at you
you're freaking out I'm just staring at
you you and Tom seura should be
brothers he I don't man I once sometimes
I think he's dead inside like he'll
he'll do things only he finds [__]
funny and I'll just go oh yeah and I
like like he make I I wish I could
remember the joke he made today
oh because on the plane I'm drunk It's
like 10 in the morning in the morning
and after taking a nude photograph of
your friend after yeah after taking a
nude photo of me by the way I looked
great that was you that was me I thought
that was Tom no no dare my body naked he
may be lighter than I am but my body is
10 million times better than his naked
that's that's the new contest dude
[__] new photo better n photo shoot
better dude we walk on the plane and
we're we're we're sitting in first class
yeah Tom walks up to the stewardess
flight attend and goes please cut him
off don't serve him any more
alcohol he whispers in her ear and we
get to our ter go what did you say he
said I I told her to cut you off I go
why the [__] would you do that and he
started
going I go [__] I want a drink and he
goes not drinking now and she served
everyone a drink except for me I go it's
not [__] funny man I go I'm I'm don't
have anything to do today I got a
podcast at 6 I'm doing Tom poas I'm
going to be loaded for that I go why the
[__] would you do that then she comes
back and I go hey can I please get a
drink and she looks at him she like he's
your Wrangler I go what the [__] man Tom
Kenny you know what your boyfriend cut
you off Tom cut you off the man in 3D
cut you off sorry sir [__] and I was
like I go it's not it's not and he was
laughing hysterically it's not funny I
it's not funny at all like there's no
joke no one's laughing except for you it
can only be you and him in on it and
you're not laughing and I'm not laughing
I'm like I wanted to drink [__]
idiot well Dave will do that like I kind
of got lucky because the way I met Dave
was like we didn't know each other that
well before we started I mean we knew
each other but we didn't know each other
that well before starting to do a
podcast and then I just found that he
was like that with people well you
saw the time I went on the podcast when
he had a Sam had
a like a anniversary show 200th episode
and there were two porn stars there
right and I just started I just started
grilling one of them cuz was really
stupid so I just started asking her
questions and I think I
said something it was something about
England where I said what's your
favorite state or something and she said
there was something where it was you
know it would be like what's your
favorite continent and someone's like
Delaware it was like one of those like
you're I start laughing at her and Sam's
getting mad and I'm just laughing at her
face because it's [__] crazy like I
get that you suck dick and put stuff in
your [__] for a living but you can read
a book when you're not doing that yeah
you can pick one up those my man [__] a
book every now and then that's what I
always put a book in your vagina one of
the best things that ever happened to me
is we were supposed to do a Vivid Video
Comedy Tour oh wow and Sam tripley and
someone else and our first date was at
riddles in Chicago and it was like man I
wish my brain was better and I could
remember this but I will tell you it was
two very famous porn stars both of which
I really wanted to [__] and I was just
at that point where like we had just had
a kid and like my wife didn't want to
have sex cuz she had just had a kid
obviously but like I was in a really
like weird place and I backed out of it
at the last minute really and whoever
replaced me ended up [__] both the
porns oh shut up that's tough at the
same time or separately oh you're just
like no more updates please on how the
night went oh wow I was like he like oh
you missed out and it's like [__]
nude I'm like are you [__] I wish I
remember the girl I don't think it was
Bri Olson but it was was like someone
that definitely was like super attracted
to I fake stabbed her to death in a
movie what you what uh fake stabbed Brie
Olson to death in a movie with your
penis uh a knife pen Penn made a movie
from Penn and Teller uh and I play a
reenactment guy and and I I like jump
out of a closet and like stab her death
and [__] [__] flies open I'm like I'm
stabbing Bri Olson's tis oh wow I did a
short one time where uh it was called
alpha male but it was spelled m a i l it
was about a mailman sure wow it was a
really good script uh this guy Terry
wrote it um I wish I you you guys would
love Terry uh anyway we had to have a a
sex scene like a sex scene really
beautiful girl and so they get us in bed
and uh and I'm in my underwear and she's
in her panties right and we pretend to
have sex well no top on okay is she hot
gorgeous okay and my dick gets really
hard yeah yeah how is it not gonna but I
was like I was so embarrassed did she
say anything uh no I just stopped and
they were like we need more of this shot
and I was like I think we got it I think
we're all wrapped I think we got it so
embarrassed my balls are calling cut
yeah my balls are going but wouldn't
wouldn't she be more offended if you
didn't get a heart on I don't know I was
so embarrassed did you did you think see
at that moment I would have winked at
her
yeah I'm finished
oh I I had to do one once do you just
stop in the middle go do you guys want
to do this
again you just look at her and go did
you come too did you come to I did one
once and it was that too where I was I
was I maintained the course as long as I
could and eventually I was like I'm only
one man and this is just one penis and I
and then and she was cool she really was
cool dude I was so embarrassed but
you're SP you're supposed to get a you
shouldn't be embarrassed you should have
jumped out of there and be like yeah
that's right I mean that's the thing
with the thing with the penis is like
it's not you're like it's not a
barometer for what I'm thinking or doing
like I'm not being a pervert my little
perverted dick is being a pervert I'm
sorry and you can rub it against a
[__] orange tree and get a heart on
like did that earlier today I came here
I scouted the place earlier I clocked it
I came in I rub my dick on Bird's tree
then I was 20 minutes late you're
welcome I I've I've had times where I
was like an orange treel
do I'm [__] I'm definitely want to
have sex tonight my daughter walked in
on me and my wife the night really how
old's your daughter 22 no I'm
kidding that never fails that never that
is always a great P it's such I I said I
want to say it was Dove David off we
were at a um we were at an audition and
Dove David off was there and they were
like uh they were like said something
like they go man they've been casting
this a while and Dub's like yeah I went
in a little bit and they go wait how
long have you been audition
this D David Goes 19
years it murdered it murdered he's
someone I wish I saw more of you guys
know Dove I've met him a couple times he
a great com he's good guy interesting
[__] guy yeah I don't know him that
one we did a show uh we did a show in
Amsterdam one time and uh he had just
gotten engaged and is they were sharing
a hotel room and she took a [__] in the
hotel room and he broke off the
engagement no what yep
no yep wait a minute
what so he was really in love with
her he was she was so beautiful she one
the most beautiful ever seen in my life
I never wanted to know that things came
out of your [__] and how I mean
the we watched him process it to break
it off in the really he was livid he was
like Hey you know do is who takes a [__]
in the [__] room you go to the lobby
you know I'm doing some fastion right
now but like he's like what the [__] he
taking his [__] in the [__] room and
we were howling in the thing and this
and she was defending herself like she's
there she in the [__] oh [__] and he
like he's like she's like I had to go to
the bathroom and he was like you don't
do it in the room yeah I'm doing a
horrible D it's it's good it's working
and and we were howling laughing and
then they broke off their engagement oh
my God she was and I will tell you this
candidly what a woman I would let [__]
on my chest she was so beautiful that's
wait wait but why why are those two
things related huh oh yeah I guess I
would let a lot of women show on my
chest really bad at that's actually an
offer of just floating out to her if you
want a squat if she said to me listen
the way I [__] is I [__] in your hands
and you put it in the toilet for me i'
be like oh done like she was gorgeous
that's a fine process and I love it Dove
and Dove just I we and he couldn't
control it he was like like he was so
like almost blown away that someone
would [__] in the hotel room yeah I but
I this is the I guess this is this is
and that's why we broke it off but this
is there is like a weird the problem
there is that if you're at the point of
Engagement you would think at least
you're aware of the person's situation
like you least that you're like that
it's some point that's come into play at
some point not at all it had never but
it's not like the first weekend they've
had away and you're like ah very well
might have been well then I guess
actually everything makes a sense if you
look at it a little logically crazy week
too Jamie kilstein was on that show oh
wow and Jamie kilstein was like I you
know he I know he's sober I don't think
he drinks at all but man I think he was
like flying a manic [__] Carpet Ride
really oh hardcore cuz he was like like
just eyes blinking a lot he's like hey
man how you doing you're like pretty
good man how you doing he's like great
working with Janine next week can't wait
can't wait Janine all right got gotta go
I got to go elevator and I was like yeah
take the stairs yeah I was like wow yeah
yeah Jamie's an interesting guy too but
that was a fun [__] was
some Hannibal burus was there and I had
a documentary film crew following me
around and Hannibal got really high and
forgot that he had met them and he
thought they were Paparazzi oh my god
wow that's great and and he
man I've never Hannibal can throw back
cocktails yeah hardcore like he we were
leaving and he went at this end of this
night and and there were wine glasses
filled and we were like yeah we're just
going to go and he's like hold on and
like [__] spaling my God sold each
one and I was like whoa and I remember
saying someone needs to watch him like
we need to get him home that's like the
uh that would be like that hawkridge
movie where that uh James Garfield Mel
Gibson movie that just came out where
the guy saved each person haar Ridge
he's like that but with the wine please
Jesus just the powerful one more have
you have you SE is it a good movie great
movie I mean I know that everybody like
you obviously there's like Mel Gibson as
a director as a human is a very touchy
subject which I you can understand but
that movie subject matter is [__]
fascinating and you know he makes like
really good gory movies he's a fantastic
filmmaker just he just lives next to the
devil or something like that his latest
beard is dude wait did you see him on
Kimmel shave that guy's head no
what it's like it it was not the best
bit cuz I guess some guy they like finds
some guy on the street and then they're
going to Mel Gibson shave his head or
give him a haircut basically Mel Gibson
just shaves this guy's head which is
ultimately always turns out into looking
like a bully move it's not it's not the
best thing Mel Gibson could have done
yeah and then the guy shaves Mel
Gibson's beard but Mel Gibson's got
something going on with like uh like I
don't know if he doesn't listen or like
uh he's okay so I he might be Riggs when
I first moved here I worked at Staple
Center for a year and I worked in the
suits and he was in the a sweet one
night and so I was taking care of him he
[__] left his he [__] left his
video camera and I chased him down and
gave it back to him and as I'm handing
it to him I'm like what in the [__] am I
doing I work at the Staple Center this
the stupidest thing it's [__] M
Gibson's home videos what the [__] yeah
you got bu theck I mean think now
knowing what you know now what are on
those St [__] right yeah it's just him
like his leg like that hurts putting a a
a what's the thing that the that the guy
and I wish I was smarter and this would
be a
mucher you're among friends what's the
thing that the guy in The Da Vinci Code
put around his leg and tightened it a
AIS no did you ever see the it's
probably not the dinino that's probably
the wrong movie was the one that Tom C
Shack no bachelor party what's the thing
it's the [__] ston it's the never
mind [__] never did you just try to
describe something and the word you used
was stunk hey Siri what's the thing that
that guy in that movie put around his
leg that Tom Hanks was in AKA ston let's
see what she
says she's you [__] up listening broke
Siri you want sushi everybody
everybody's Siri in the entire country
just shut down wait the guy put sushi on
his leg have you done that on a podcast
no I I did that on Rogan and a lot of
people got pissed wait what yeah if you
say Hey Siri they just stopped listening
to the podcast oh is that true it stops
everyone's phone so someone on a someone
on a oh [__] that's crazy someone on a
uh on a a news program somewhere I heard
about this sh what's the name of the
Amazon one uh Alexa ala said hey Alexa
and and to order something and
everyone's [__] everybody was
listening to the show it Alexa started
ordering didn't Alexa say something
crazy I heard that Alexa said some like
Alexa said something to the level of
like I'll never die or something like
weird like that oh she gets weird if you
get really deep into her what see are
you [__] Alexa you know what I do you
know what I do on radio sometimes I'll
go hey Siri put it in my calendar that
Burke chry is at the Buffalo Helium
Comedy Club and actually call The Helium
Club now ask for tickets hey Siri take
my credit card and charge 10 tickets to
The Helium Comedy Club in Buffalo New
York do it
now um
anyway that joke F that whatever my
thought was we fell apart because I it's
it's very specific I don't the M thing
but you realize how great it would be if
you had video of M dude and but you had
sat on it you sat on it right
[__] I blew it man we found a we found a
ring in SeaWorld uh it's a diamond ring
with um emeralds all over it it's very
expensive ring we found in SeaWorld
there's an description I put a video on
my YouTube looking for the owner
MH my wife the other day was like hey
when can we like cash in on that ring I
go never it's not ours I go I'm waiting
for the owner I go in 20 years when they
reach out to me and they're like hey
Bert thank you that was my mother's ring
I go do you realize what that'll do for
me everyone be like God damn it man you
had this ring for 20 years and you
waited for it and lean's like [__]
let's get a new car like wait that's not
how it works I think I think I'm on your
wife's side yeah it's a [__] great
Ring it's like big diamonds you know I
lost one there recently really no but uh
the inscription there's an inscription
that's the best part of it so like dear
BT give it back mine uh it's my the
inscription because it's it's my ring
it's it says hey
[__] I don't know Dave imagine taking
that ring to get that incription and
it's from the 1900s he [__] when a [__]
was a car when a [__] was a
car okay wait so so your daughter walks
in on you [__] oh right so I throw a
temper tantrum okay wait you're upset
who's on top my wife okay so I throw a
temper tantrum cuz my daughter wants to
sleep with us okay I I go to the other
room we just put uh added a room another
room for the girls I go to that room my
wife comes in she does this thing where
like she like I like she go you want to
just have a quickie and it bothers me
cuz I'm like no I want to have sex I
want to I want to like get into it she's
like just have a quickie and she it's a
bully move my wife's a bully right she
really is like I was telling Tom today I
go she's a in at heart she's a [__]
she'll come back here you'll see her and
just try to read it off her face okay
she is a [__] like I I think so but in
like a good turn you know there a lot of
wom um but she's a hardcore bully I woke
up the other morning she's sitting on my
lap and the girls are laying on my arms
and I go what are you guys doing and
they're like we know you don't like your
belly button being [__] with I was
like what and they [__] touch my
belly
button sensitive area [__] do not
like that no that would freak me out so
my wife comes in and then I go fine and
then she makes me laugh cuz when she
bullies it makes me laugh and then she
gets on top of me we start trying to get
it going and my daughter comes in
sobbing crying she's like I thought you
would sleep with me tonight and I was
like my wife's totally naked oh my God
and has to like put on clothes she like
hold on hold on isa's crying in the
hallway I thought you'd sleep with me
tonight I'm just like what a [__]
[__] block just a quickie yeah I was
like five minutes come on and then in my
head including cleanup I thought so so
she never realized you guys were doing
it I don't know wow I don't think so we
haven't really no confirmation how old
10 I walked in on my parents when I was
10 and it was super weird really yeah
like I like like you I mean because I
don't think I fully like was on top not
me not this kid this kid had to go to
his room and think for a
[Music]
while the ladies there get out of here
ma'am but I like but I don't think I
fully had like an understand you know I
didn't understand fully what like sex
was and cuz I mean you know this is
before you could just watch porno
wherever you wanted and you need to know
a kid who had like a Woods near his
house and uh but so like I was it like
took me a minute to process and then
when I finally did I was like what the
[__] is their problem you know I really
was like G I was so grossed out by it it
was so where you grow up Wisconsin
really yeah where did you grow up uh
North of San Francisco oh how great is
your life it's not bad not bad that's so
cool it's a [__] great place to grow
up it's so beautiful I love Wisconsin in
the Summers and everyone goes out to the
lake yeah oh the uh flat mosquitoes yeah
the mosquitoes are bad [__] Brut yeah
because they're like they're feeding
yeah they get fat I mean there's some
you know the ones where like you hit one
and it and it just looks like it ate
like Thanksgiving you're just like oh no
and you know that it's like some of
yours but it's also like it's my
neighbor's blood have you ever got a
mosquito to bite on you and then flexed
blows them up right it lock gets locked
in and it can't pull its nose out
seriously yeah but Florida the
mosquitoes were super bad can I tell you
what what ignorance I grew up with we
were at a at in Tampa growing up and
there was a gay nightclub next door to
where we were partying and there were
mosquitoes out and everyone's like we're
I'm going to get AIDS oh God that that
was like I always say like I wish I wish
someone just acknowledged how ignorant
my childhood was to go hey man you make
great strides to be a a regular person
yeah like no one acknowledges that you
can only get squir you get AIDS from
squirrels what but not uh how do you
[__] a squirrel it's you just got to put
it near your
nuts two 19
years yeah
you get age from a squirrel who found
this out who's the guy who's like hey uh
Charlie can I tell you something between
us I got AIDS and I haven't had sex with
a woman in 5 years but we got this Nest
near me boy oh boy that's how Bernard
gets got hey before this meeting starts
FYI you get from a squirrel all right
now let's talk about the quarterly
numbers where are we with that yeah you
can squirrels so we're spiking how we
doing let's talk numbers guys you can
get a from squirrel how do you know this
information and how that is that true
[Laughter]
no I'm going to pass
out if we all passed out that would be
amazing oh my God what a great what a
great myself I can laugh myself to pass
out I I See Stars sometimes when I laugh
I wait are you in Hollywood oh yeah I'll
stop yeah I always wish that someone
would acknowledge that like I did not
grow up uh super open-minded like that
was that wasn't the way my friends were
there was no no one like there was I
there was no I you know now I think
about it I didn't know one liberal
person seriously until I was until I
moved to New York but there are there
are liberal people in Florida no I even
know really I mean like I'll I'll tell
you what i' I've said this uh I wrote
this in my book like when I was in a
fraternity the nare was thrown around a
lot yeah like a lot but not but not even
like not even about black people as much
it was like right when qu Tarantino came
out like everyone used that word like it
was just it was like part of the
vernacular and uh and there was no I
mean
like I don't I this is going to sound
super horrible and I but I mean to be
honest so that anyone else hears this
goes oh yeah yeah yeah I understand I'm
the same way I didn't have sincere
sensitivity for using the word uh the f
word [__] why why why would I even say
the f word I like how you said the f
word and then you said it but like it's
so confusing but like until Todd Glass
had that Marin when Todd Glass was on
Marin talked about being gay it really
opened my eyes and I went and like I
just didn't care not not that I used the
word a lot but I didn't care like it was
just like I was like I I didn't
understand the effect of like oh that's
a gay shirt or that's it was also it was
also I mean that that is the thing with
like I mean language and the idea of
when you change your P your perspective
gets changed when you're actually
confronted with those things so if
you're not raised around any of that
stuff and you only hear one thing I mean
it's like people who are raised in a
cult I mean you know or Amish you
believe this [__] because your parents
are like telling you and it's what
you're seeing around you and stuff like
that but you know language
changes there was a time when everybody
would say that and would say it you know
with Venom behind it and then it got to
the point where it wasn't that it was
more like a joke that you would call
someone that like if they didn't catch a
ball right or something and then you're
like oh no now you can't you know and
you slowly eventually you know are
trying to find the terms that we can
agree on uh that are as sensitive as
possible it's one of the things do you
guys feel like this I feel like you guys
probably see a broader spectrum of
Comedy than I see like one of the things
that bums me out about comedy is like I
go I go I know What affected change in
me like I know like and dead seriously
Todd glasses
Marin like literally changed me like it
changed me as a human being I went I
went oh I'd love Todd and I would never
want Todd to ever feel like I didn't
accept his lifestyle or accept what he
wanted what his heart wanted you know
what I mean and and then more
importantly I was like and I never saw
that perspective of a young um kid going
through struggles with his sexuality and
then hearing me a guy you might like on
TV and going oh I like this guy and then
I go oh this is the gayest rod and then
the guy goes oh so now I my lifestyle
sucks yeah but what I what bums me out
and this might not be accurate and you
and feel free to correct me is like I
feel like that now what is happening is
there's a bunch of agenda driven comedy
where it's like this is my point of view
I'm going to shove it down your throat
and I go I don't know if that's
affecting change the
way like the the one thing I can say is
like the way Todd did or like you
know uh when Trayvon Martin died uh when
got murdered his mom came on and said
like uh said something and his dad and I
I think a lot of people probably looked
at his mom and dad in a certain way but
I saw his dad and I was like oh man he
just lost his kid like and it was it
really blew me away and I was like so
many people now are taking agendas like
I love Amy Schumer I I'm not [__] on
Amy at all I love Amy I'm will forever
be friend to Amy as long as I live but I
can speak freely cuz I I know her but
like uh like when she did the thing
about Trump and like and like kicked the
people the guy out of not kicked her out
of the show but brought the guy on stage
I was like that's not wait I didn't even
know what she did she uh said is anyone
voting for Trump and here and a guy came
on stage and then they had a back and
forth and it did not go well I meaning
I'm I'm certain her intention was to
make it funny yeah but it was not funny
and then the guy was embarrassed and I
think he left and then they boo her and
then it in Florida oddly enough my
hometown was in Tampa oddly enough and
then I was booing there no it was in
Tampa I grew
up shocker and and but I go and then I
go like and like the stuff with the
what's the girl from girls
uh got to shut the [__] up but like I go
you're not I don't know if you're
affecting change the way no she's not I
don't I don't even know if they she the
opposite of affecting change she's
making people feel like [__] it's a
really weird place right now too because
you everybody's very on edge PE anybody
who is is for Trump is very defensive
and anybody who's anti-trump I mean it's
a lot like the remember that the blue
and black dress when everyone was like
this dress is blue everyone it's like
when you have arguments with with people
or you even see arguments as an observer
online you're like it it's just people
are very very reactive
a hard time to find comedy by being like
I totally disagree with you for
everybody I mean you know but I I like
what what Amy did was yeah like you said
it was it's what it is what it is it's
like you know what to be dead honest
with you don't ever critique what I do
on stage from afar because I'm trying to
do something it may not work but [__]
you you weren't there you Wen me you
didn't have the money so like I'm not
critiquing Amy in that situation but I
part of me goes like whatever happened
to
like like why can't there be more people
like Todd Glass that's what I think in
in the sense of being more honest you
mean and and disgusting in that way uh
yeah vulnerable too there's a there's a
vulnerability with that at first you
know he did well he he's also telling a
story you know what I mean yeah as
opposed to pushing an agenda right he's
just because that's what changes Minds
is is is telling a story from okay so uh
I used to do a podcast with Greg Baron
called walk in the room and we really
[__] dirty filthy like it was just a
filthy [__] podcast love Greg Baron
yeah he's the best I love Greg Baron
yeah such a good [__] comic dude yeah
his his his Comedy Central half hour is
still one of the best comedy central
half hours you'll ever see he's great so
uh what was I talking about you used to
podcast with Greg Barrett oh so uh so we
used to say the word [__] all that
time and uh and then people were like
you can't [__] say [__] it's
offensive blah blah blah and I was like
Jesus Christ like that in no way did I
ever mean in a defensive term like you
know blah blah blah and then someone
just sent me a big [__] letter just
explaining from their perspective of why
it was a bummer to hear that and then
they never said it again yeah yeah
that's the part where I go I go that's
what's missing in this dialogue like
maybe it's story maybe it's like someone
going hey this is my personal experience
like you know someone said to me
um [__] it
uh I reached out to Ria butcher uh to be
on my podcast uh I I find I think the
her and car Cameron Cameron Cameron are
both very funny but I really find Ria
funny like I and I mean I just I just
connected with her very quickly and so I
just sent her a direct message and I was
like I would love to have you on my
podcast I'd love to have both of you on
my podcast obviously but like I mean
also I know you're individual you don't
have to be a team so if you want to do
my podcast individually great if Cameron
like to come I'd love to have her as
well um and she was really having a hard
time with the the Trump election uhhuh I
didn't get it I really didn't get it and
I was like oh my God and then I talked
to someone and they're like no you
realize that like all gay rights can
totally be taken away now and I was like
what I was like wait what what's
happening cuz none of this like you know
when Trump got elected I was with the 90
I elected I was with four wealthy white
males right and all of us were like
whatever yeah know cuz it doesn't affect
wealthy white males it actually kind of
helps
us really kind of helps us like no
offense this election's been [__]
win-win for me oh no I mean it's sad to
say and I get to see an assassination
this is going to be
amazing this is a movie preview I'm
living [__]
seriously I've always wanted to walk my
apartment like what's going on oh you
don't know I
but like uh the Bible that he was about
to put his hand on blew up but but uh
but but yeah it and I didn't you know I
I don't think you know the things that
like like Mexican people man like yeah
oh
yeah can you imagine the fear of losing
your parents like I think that really is
the perspective that is so crazy when
you think about a kid raised here now
thinking no no connection to Mexico been
here the whole [__] since they were
like one has always been here but
they're illegal and then they get cuz
people get [__] sent back to these
countries and they're like I don't know
and it's their parents it's like you're
worried about your like you remember
when you're a kid like the stress you
feel over your parents and like
preserving your parents and your parents
not having sex in front of you when
you're 10 God sorry I'm getting
sidetracked but uh you you you have this
sort of like you worry about your
parents in this weird sort of way and
then if you I mean some some of you
worried about your parents how
let's let's wait let's half full this
and go how sweet would it be if you're
15 and your parents get sent to Mexico
and you're like oh guess m drop [__] I
got parties this weekend son 20th
Century Fox presents I'll take care of
the house
deported deported deported house party
July 4th house deported house deported
house deported
too I would my if I was 16 and they were
like your parents are going back to
Ireland I'd be like H done son come on B
you're coming with us no I'm not USA
[__] Jess's driving a Mercedes to
school [__] put on your dad's watch
holy [__] it's like you're living like a
body switch movie but without the
fountain it's like home alone but with
Mexicans this is probably by the way
someone's definitely going to complain
about this like yeah it's a very serious
subject bir it's really
serious well yeah well we are saying
it's sir I mean it's like it is crazy
that that that is like but then I I just
go like I I wish people uh I don't know
I don't know whatever okay that was a
good thought yeah I wish I was smarter
so I could say things that I think but
then I I get high and I'm like yeah I
have like paragraph thoughts in my head
pot does that that's so high last night
I like pot so he gives me so I I used to
smoke pot all the time I don't think
I've had the followup to this oh I guess
you haven't so so I'm going I'm going
away you know for Christmas and we go up
North and I drop my kid at my sister's
house and then we how's your kid
seven what yeah just one that girl boy
boy yeah he's [__] great home run why
you have another one you already got the
boy plays [__] baseball he's great
that's why I had two I was looking for
the boy yeah My Buddy Miles goes keep
knocking the dicks
off can you check inside there for a
dick sir I think he might have dropped
it yeah and if he's my boy it's a big
one plays baseball uh he's a Phenom oh
seven he's playing with N9 and 11 year
olds already they moved him up a leak
yeah he's like a young Ru but with a
brain hits s years old hits in the
batting cage 65 M hour 70 mph pitches
from both sides of the plate he really
is crazy [__] seven hold on it's
crazy he turned his first triple
unassisted triple play when he was five
like it's nuts to watch wait is this bad
to say can I go watch your kid play
baseball my daughter's playing softball
I mean this is a bit I'm doing it's it's
so
this will be a bit that you're about to
hear this is true okay I go to their
practice coach isn't using a ball he
doesn't want them to fail right yeah it
doesn't want him to fail that's what
[__] Sports is wait what's he using
an imaginary ball no wait is this not
soft ball what the [__] is this this is
these are soft lies this you could argue
the ball is the most important part of
the game it's it's I mean if you think
it's the headliner softball softball
ball is that soft soft soft ination and
he's out is anybody trapped in a box on
the field yeah out there cuz he wants
them to learn where the play is so he's
like all right here we go ladies run on
first and second ground ball Lily here
we go makes a noise swings
away ground ball Lily what do you do and
then she FS it perfectly welcome she's
got great hands on the imagin what if
she what if she didn't
though so my daughter's in center field
this is ISA my 10-year-old yeah all
right Bas is loaded
Fly ball to ISA and I watch my daughter
I'm I swear to you I swear to you on
their
lives stop freeze look up and then start
backing up oh my God and then turn
around and start running like it went
over a [__] head cuz she's watched
baseball there's no [__] yeah there's
no [__] ball I go who fails in their
own imagination I go are you [__] me
and throw your in the air like like I
couldn't [__] judge it it came off
the it came off the sound so fast yeah
I couldn't focus the th fans are
throwing beer on me the coach she the
coach was like I guess I hit it over her
head yeah with the best the best part of
the storying the best part of the story
is I I call my wife I go you're never
going to believe your idiot daughter
just did she was like what I tell her
she goes don't bring it up she goes you
know one of the favorite things
especially when you have a kid is like
when you call your spouse and go guess
what I it's the greatest feeling in the
world she goes don't [__] with this like
that's her brain and it makes us laugh
and so don't shame her so we get in the
car and I go but I can't help it I'm
like yo Isa what happened with that fly
ball she didn't even miss a beat staring
out the window like a stoner and goes
yep coach really got a hold of that
one just a weird [__] no but I can
tell you exactly what it is there's
nothing more boring when you're a kid
than being in the Outfield oh so she
[__] just Ram with with her
imagination cuz she's bored out of her
[__] mind she stands in the Outfield
got a hold of itar she stands in the
Outfield that's my ride got a roll she
stands in the Outfield and just looks
for bees she's terrified of bees oh
that's why she wants to be a catcher cuz
hilarious there's no the dirt right yeah
weird but uh Isa is a much better
softball player than Georgia but they
both have beautiful swings but I found
that softball coaches [__] up my kids
swings so I played I played competitive
baseball up until uh College I got
recruited to play at Duke in the Citadel
and then went to Florida State walked on
and then quit the first day and really
yeah but like was a legit baseball like
I mean what position catcher uh catcher
Third Base left field but I caught a
dude who went pro and because I caught
him everyone was like well then he can
catch anywhere right and so uh went pro
almost won the sa Young Award oddly
enough whoa um the rubell yeah and so uh
but I've taken very big strides on my
daughter's swings like I've go I went
through drills with them on how to swing
like how to break the wrists
and uh and coaches always [__] it up
always [__] it up always they always do
so we we had a tournament team this
summer and did you play baseball growing
up yeah yeah uh we had a tournament team
in this this summer and uh so most of
the kids are just starting to [__]
swing and learn this [__] and Finn has a
natural swing like the I there's a guy
who we take him to a camp and he's an
expro guy and he goes he goes don't do
anything dud nothing more beautiful than
a kid with a natural SP my buddy Cay
lazera had the most beautiful swing
you've ever seen in your life there was
this kid Brucey that when it ended up
playing
Miami the most beautiful swing and you
just went oh that's just gorgeous like
just effortless right yeah you see it
and you're like what's happening right
there yeah yeah so he was just born with
this [__] swing and we put him on
this tourament team and then they the
coaches like oh we're going to have him
go to this place we're going to we're
going to work on their swinging it's
like an indoor place where they be a
Pitch to him and I just watched them
break him down until he didn't know what
he was
doing and I was like I just yanked him
after like three of those cuz he was
just his swing was just [__] all of a
sudden and I'm just like no and then I
talk to that expr guy and he goes he
goes you don't don't do anything to that
kid just let him just let him hit yeah
let him hit he'll if you need to tweak
things as he gets older you'll be able
to do it he goes steroids are going to
be a thing you're going to need to put
in him okay yeah I mean that's it I I'd
never had a a great swing he's a he's a
catcher too he loves catching he [__]
he throws guy's out he's seven heun we
were playing we were playing we were
playing a fall yeah he seven he's seven
we were playing Triple Play we're
playing fall ball this this he was
playing with the nine and 9 to 11 years
old and they see him and and the coach
is like I just run on him and he and and
I go Finn I go Finn this kid's going to
run because usually they wait till he
drop the ball in that age and I go he's
just going to run so I go gun him down
and I yell it across the cuz I want
everybody to know that to happen not who
I imagine Dave to be come on that Dad oh
yeah oh yeah I can see it I go Finn G
him down every looks at me and I'm just
like watch and he and he catches it and
he jumps up and the kid is like the
kid's like 10 and he's and he's running
and he can't believe when he gets in the
base that the ball is already there he
just stop gets tagged out he just gets
tagged out and everyone's like what just
happened I'm like don't [__] run on
my kid
oh like all right so that's it you are
absolutely out of here was like that's
right they don't run on you Finn you
want to hear something crazy so I go I I
get extremely competitive yeah I you
don't see no one ever sees that in me
but I'm very very competitive so I had a
really hard time watching the girls play
softball because I'm not I'm not home
enough to to be able to coach yeah but I
know so much more than their coaches and
it just makes me crazy it drives you
that's I'm I'm a big soer guy and
watching these Soccer Coaches I want to
blow my brains out I I have I end up in
the Outfield uh and usually I'll smoke
pot and just sit in the Outfield and
just go I can't deal dude there's a
bunch of parents when you get to the
major leagues in in this league we're in
who go to the Outfield and sit in the
Outfield cuz they can't take it right I
man I'm that's amazing and like and like
the Island of Misfit Toys it's it's it's
an instinct to like go to go
just to jump in I I can't shut my mouth
off right yeah so I go to the Outfield I
get high one day we're playing a a team
from uh deep in the Valley Mexican all
Mexican yeah very by the way uh say
whatever you want to say about me but I
will say that uh Mexican the Mexican
teams are a lot more competitive than
the white teams like the girl like the
coaches are more involved like the white
teams it just seems like and I'm just
telling you my experience whatever this
ISAC but yeah yeah yeah well well so we
get done the game and it's a much more
competitive game the girls are stealing
home the girls are stealing every base
and our my do oldest daughter is like
like barely doing anything in the game
we get in the car I'm high I both my
daughters and my wife is driving and my
oldest daughter just goes I don't think
I like
Mexicans
go I go what she goes I don't I don't
know if I like Mexicans they seem very
aggressive and I go and know I'm super
hot right I'm super hot and I go oh my
God no you don't like poor
people she goes what I go those it has
nothing to do with their skin color
those those girls are underprivileged so
this is their moment you know this is
their like you have a lot of [__] to do
today their day might be over I don't
but they're from a poor area of town so
you don't like poor people my wife's
like the [__] you saying hey B don't
help right now huh can you not help so
much high as [__] I'm like no you don't
like poor people my wife's like shut the
[__] up we should get Mexican food not
now like all like they they could have
been white people but if they're poor
that's who you don't like it's got I
don't want you to be racist I want you
to be
classist I'm obsessed with this thought
by the way that no one likes poor people
in this country oh yeah obsessed with
this thought Oh no you're right I had
this thought where we were talking uh I
guess wringling brothers and B belly
yeah you got bummed about that a dud I
was so they treat the elephants like
[__] garbage oh yeah well here's the
thing I'm a big I'm a big okay okay can
I just say this out loud and then you
you Pro quit proquo me yeah so like it's
the sins of our fathers like they're
like the what the elephants like yeah
like like well no like SeaWorld like
what are we going to like things already
the [__] thing like what do we do
with it well okay so C's different cuz
you can't really release those you can't
release but an elephant put on a [__]
elephant Farm in an elephant place I
think that's a technical term yeah no
you obviously D my dad's like this like
so when you remember when Opie and
Anthony uh imploded with the Anthony's
thing yeah uh my dad was like hardcore
like you know that [__] guy I go yeah
he's like he's a [__] idiot and I was
like he's a nice guy and he's like no
you're an idiot for saying he's a nice
guy I go no he's he's not a bad guy he's
like it's [__] not black people it's
not it's not black people have no
problem with [__] violence it's not
black people it's [__] poor people
it's underprivileged people
underprivileged people get he goes
doesn't matter what color you are when
you're poor you sometimes violence is
your answer because you don't have any
other options and I was like I was like
that's an interesting concept but my
whole thing about like SeaWorld was like
or not in ringland Brothers is like this
may be the only opportunity for an
underprivileged child to see something
different in the
world okay all right that's an argument
and like and that's like someone was
like uh this girl said something and and
I was like I was like she's like it's
much better to see these animals in the
wild I was like yeah agreed agreed
totally agreed and I have that
opportunity I definitely have taken my
daughters to swim with sharks in the
wild right I've taken them uh I I've
been on Safari I've done a lot of stuff
but I had that opportunity for like some
kid who who whose only opportunity is
going to be the one field trip he gets
to the the zoo or to SeaWorld or to
that's his only thing his mom's I'm just
making this kid up but his mom's
addicted to crack his dad's not there
and he goes on a field trip to SeaWorld
and then he inspires and he goes oh
there so there's more than just [__]
tennis shoes thrown over a [__]
telephone wire like there's more in this
world like that's part of me the other
part of me obviously is a it realizes
it's I saw the documentary too it was
horrible what they did to those [__]
whales well it really is it I mean and I
think you know that I think that is
totally a fair point it's I guess it's
the
uh at some point you have to think about
the life of the animal over as well like
with value to it as well age and your
point with SeaWorld is one that I think
you know what their plan is that there
there will be no more whale captivity
but there are still other animals in
captivity that could and that's the
thing with the circus too is the circus
is like active torture to the animals
and Sh like that very okay so so like
they were in Florida I think when this
happened um the ring brother you must
get sick of all every time something
[__] I never even knew that that was
about my state like everyone was and I
was like I was like and then it started
like I was like yeah man I'm hearing
Florida a lot right like Florida is a
weird [__] big player in the weird
game Ron Ben you guys know Ron benon no
oh my
God I swear to you all my children
possibly the greatest broadcaster that's
ever lived really
really
amazing he said to me he lived in
Florida for a while and he goes yeah
Florida's [__] up he goes did you know
a lot of guys missing fingers I go yeah
oh my God too do you know that's not
normal most people don't have that I go
I said to him I go I know two dudes that
don't have
tongues I'm not [__] around how do
that happen I got I know a guy named
tongas Brett and a guy
named like [__] FL is different man
it just is really really different I
can't believe his parents named him
tongas yeah well time to fulfill my
destiny
snip so what were we gonna say what were
we gonna say about circus wait but how
did tongas brat L's tongue I don't know
I just know him from cowe head in a
finger argument um so they're down there
in Florida one of the elephants comes
out it's it's it's super it's not doing
well and they and there's there's
supposed to be a there's a law
that if an elephant isn't doing well for
a certain amount of time a vet has to
come and look at it do you think it
would be a kind of a no-brainer rule too
right but they had to make it a law
because they weren't doing that so the
vet comes in and the and the Elephant is
clearly [__] up like there's something
wrong with it it's got It's it's got
diarrhea like terrible diarrhea well
that'll be fun for the kids to see it's
super well that's it it first had
diarrhea during a [__] Show Oh that's
oh they'd go I'd go nuts for that I mean
honestly honestly at this point that's
that would be the show you'd want to see
that like Wrangler being like he won't
stop [__] while an elephant just has
food poisoning on
dirt under a
tent while the ring Master is stepping
in [__] hey all right guys a this isn't
supposed to happen bring out the clowns
slides across the [__] to watch the
fourth wall be broken and like this
isn't real everybody stop recording
clowns take off your makeup we're all
cleaning up poop what if the clowns
start [__] we ate the peanuts too
not again like oh we ate the peanuts
too we ate the peanuts
too so he just comes out so the so the
vet so the vet gets there and the the
elephants start [__] blood and the
vet's like oh he just got a stomach
thing and they send this elephant out
vet that's the thing they probably just
[__] paid off the vet vet right yeah
I would think Florida vet with no tongue
he had Gatorade he must have Dr Gatorade
certainly a [__] P vet he's got a
stomach problem yeah yeah he's a Florida
vet did he eat any blood he's got like
no nose one ear yeah uh three
fingers fing also tongas Brett doesn't
have a tongue anymore tless Brett's a
real dude and he is listening to this
I'm certain of it
[Music]
going oh anything like that how much you
want to bet I get an email that says hey
by the way tongas breads
died
tly they bued him right next to his
tongue you call him cuz his T his tongue
had its own funeral sweet what happens
with the elephant so the elephant goes
out and does a laxidasical show cuz it's
[__] blood yeah and then uh and then
goes back in and they put it in its
[__] pen and it's dead in the
morning Well you certainly have a good
end story that ends with like a chicken
like story oh yeah it's got a nice
chicken yeah my my problem is like I'm
not I think I'm disconnected also from
my feelings like I think my feelings
were that as a child that's very helpful
for comedy yeah well I saw I saw in
Russia they had uh they had um bears
that rode bicycles wait what a they had
bears that I that's like a that's like a
cartoon thing you see it's real there
how do you how do you how do you have to
break the will of a bear to get it on a
bicycle cattle prod
[__] and they had them in their hands no
dude they can I tell you what they did
this will blow you away they had like a
say like a 2x4 like a a 15t 2x4 and they
would have the bear stand on it like a
balancing beam and theyd throw it 10t in
the air and it would land on the [__]
Tu by far because if it
didn't yeah if it doesn't you know how I
learn to do that 5 million
[__] and I and I I'll be dead honest
with you when I saw that my heart was
broken and I was like that that is not
cool but but hell pretty amazing show I
mean when you see a bear ice skating
you're like shut the I can bar the ice
how the [__] do you teach a be to ice he
landed it he landed the spin just it uh
the problem the problem with elephants
is is they're one of the smartest
animals yeah they they have families
like extended families and when like
when a family M dies mourn yeah they
like mourn like [__] like they're like
they're way Advanced over most animals
so yeah the fact that they're [__] up
like that is I have a problem I've
always had a problem with I've had a
genuine inherent problem with animals in
captivity because you go to the zoo and
you look at the lion and you're like
that's not what a lion is no the [__]
the LA Zoo that remember that hippo that
died finally but it was like in a
swimming pool and you're like how's your
life dude yeah I've seen lions in the
wild and lions in the wild lay different
than W lions in captivity yeah you know
it's it's it's a like you see the lions
at LA Zoo and they're like they're not
enjoying anything they've been rofi and
then you see lions in in the wild and
they are you can see it in their eyes
you can see the life in their eyes
they're like whoa it's the same thing
when you go to a brothel and then you go
to like can I can I tell you can I tell
you I swam with dolphins like I swam
with dolphins in Mexico it's like I
think one of the play only places you
could do this but I got in the water
with them did your daughter was your
daughter like I don't like Mexican
Dolphins no no it was uh no you just
don't like poor Dolphins you don't like
poor
pits the uh it was in Mexico and we were
it was for Travel Channel and they were
like hey you're going to get in the tank
with dolphins you can ride them like
stand on their backs and stuff hold
their fins you can do whatever you want
you could and I was like it was really
interesting CU I thought I had a very
quick connection with them because I was
like they're they look like strippers
like they feel like strippers that
energy that you get in a strip club
it's disconnected these [__] poor
dophins had that energy and I was just
like I was like man I don't feel really
cool with this like like it's fine it's
fine and they did the thing where they
put their beaks on your feet and they
get you to stand up they they take off
and I was like I was like it was really
cool it was fun but it was like at the
same time I was like I think my heart's
broken a little bit like I I lost
something like and and then I swam with
dolphins in Hawaii in the Open Water
yeah and it was that's one of the
greatest feelings I've ever had in my
life where you get in Bottle noos
dolphins and or I think that's what it
was and you're just diving down and
they're [__] racing around you and
you're like oh my God you have an energy
that's totally different right because
they're almost they're sharing an
experience potentially they're playing
they're when you see the dolphins in
Hawaii you can't believe how much
they're just playing and having fun yeah
so so then okay be very real about this
is there is there any positivity to any
animal ever in
captivity well is there any benefit yes
if they are going
extinct I I would say I would say that I
mean I I think that there like you can't
I think your point before is true like
potentially some kid goes to the zoo he
sees a monkey in a cage and he's
obsessed with monkeys and then he goes
on to be Jane Goodall and like you know
that's potentially something that
happens somebody is super inspired by
but outside of that the the mean quality
of of everyone's life if you lumped it
into a pile is is much less um when
those animals are are held captive I
believe you know you can see how bummed
they are when you go to a zoo they it's
like and that guilt you're talking about
is I think that is that's something that
a lot of people feel it's you know it's
hard to engage in that [__] it's hard to
a lot of times look at that stuff and go
you know what like I like looking at a
lion but that's just [__] up you know
and like it it is a I think it's a hard
again it's like everything else it's
like when when the circus started nobody
gave a [__] oh [__] no you know you were
seeing animals up close people in cages
I mean that's what a circus oh yeah
these things all started as freak shows
they used to just put a black guy in a
cage and be like there's a pygmy because
he was black like they did the craziest
[__] [__] wow horrendous dude Oda
benga that was the remember that we
talked about the show yeah yeah they put
a guy put a a lady or a guy well they
but they just put him in a cage and
we're like there's a black people come
out be like check out the black guy like
[__] nuts dude what uh what I mean I
mean part of you says then I mean part
of me feels like I'm cool with
absolutes like the thing I the thing I
get hung up on is uh people who don't
have like people who it seems like they
cut the corners for whatever their
opinion are is so like I'm cool I'm
totally cool letting animals be animals
yeah but we got to go across the board
then I think right we got a free people
no no just get rid of all zoos like I'm
houses I I to me that that would make
sense I mean to me like don't don't
split hairs and go you can't have a a
killer whale yeah but you can have like
monkeys well the [__] monkeys are as
important as killer whales I think
you're right I mean that to me I I think
that that's true I mean you can't like I
I but I wonder if there is
a middle ground well like like a like a
[__] big Safari place like I wonder
if there's a way to create a gigantic
zoo that has tons of land and even
though they're restrict cuz cuz really
those animals a lot of them are pretty
Territorial and a lot of times they
stick to the same area or they migrate
back and forth we went to the one in the
San Diego Zoo they have yeah how's that
one I've never been in the San Diego zo
like it's really big open space right by
the way [__] lit me up about SeaWorld
we're in the we're doing the Safari with
the girls and our friends and I said
something about I said H this is so
great it really is it's like a golf
basically it's a golf course I think I
think it was a golf course in all
honesty maybe not but it the Bears play
golf yeah it looks like a golf course
and it's just all [__] the Bears are
caddies it's amazing it's like pitching
Bush Gardens is [__] pretty amazing
Tampa the animals run free for the most
part yeah I mean not free but they get
like a couple acres yeah yeah and uh and
I said I made a joke about what well
there's also a version of this where
that a lot of times that is the way
they'll kind of re rehabilitate an
animal who has been in captivity it's
almost like you go to like a um you know
like a h it's almost like you go under
housing before they let you out in the
Free World it's like rehab it's like you
do you do rehab then you go to your
halfway house one of those yeah yeah
yeah it's the DS but so there would be a
way where you could be constantly
rehabilitating before you let into the
wild and let people sort of watch that
version of we do like can we do like a a
bay where we keep killer whales like
meaning not not keep them but like the
ones that are in captivity now can't we
release them into like a bay where they
have like a like or something bigger
than what they're in I don't know I the
I mean the I mean potentially the
problem with SeaWorld is that like you
know like like anything they're not
going to say what's really going on yeah
because of money right like so no matter
you it's hard to know I mean that CU
that does sound like it makes sense but
again you know they're like look we've
got this [__] facility we got these
whales let's keep the ship you know keep
business together they're they're having
a really rough time oh they're done and
marine land too what's I don't know what
that is like Canadian Sea World oh yeah
the um the when I did the tour the the
zoo tour with the girls where we do like
a safari in San Diego I made a joke
about SeaWorld and this [__] lady lit
me up [__] A lady did front of my
children my wife our friends and the
other people on the thing she was like
you have no idea what you just said you
are ruining you are the problem with
with uh with with conservation and
animals and she and I and I go I'm just
making a joke she goes no SeaWorld's
done more good for [__] marine
biology than anyone and I was like I go
I was just making a job I'm a comedian
and everyone was uncomfortable my
friends are laughing hysterically I'm so
a girl whispered in her ear oh he's like
he's like hey and but I was making a
joke going like yeah they should do this
with whatever and she was like and it
turns out I mean every zoologist every
marine biologist every one of those
people feels like SeaWorld's good like
what they've done is good because
they've inspired people to to work with
animals I guess I mean I don't know I
don't really I honestly and I say this
to you guys both I don't think I need to
say this but like I don't really have a
a whale in this fight in that I don't
really give a [__] I don't really go to
seaw world anyway yeah like I I it sucks
I'm sorry I can't get P I don't have a
whale on this fight I a wh this fight
yeah but but like I go like it's just
the biggest problem with this country is
that if it does affect me I don't give a
[__] yeah and the biggest problem in
this country it's like it's like the
Trump everyone's losing their mind
totally you know what it doesn't affect
49% of the people 49% of the people just
did like they go H whatever I think you
do I think you're right that uh most
people need to feel an effect of
something before they become an activist
for it that's like the the not and like
that is really true that it always seems
strange to me and this is going to
probably sound rude but when somebody
would get a disease like maybe a famous
person or something like that and they
would go to Congress and they talk on
behalf of it and they are a hero this is
not saying that that is not a great
thing and that you don't want like more
stem cells put towards researching this
disease but the over embracing of
somebody who's got such a vested
interest in the Breakthrough of this has
always been a little like are we over
embracing like it makes sense can I tell
you my one of my favorite jokes ever
told Patrice O'Neal oh boy he was like
uh I'm watching a I'm watching a news
the other day and Michael J fox comes on
and he's like talking about Parkinson's
he's standing next to Muhammad Ali
trying to
[Applause]
outshopped there and he's talking about
Parkinson he's like I'd want one person
just to go hey man Michael J fox what
about like AIDS and cancer and I would
love Michael J fox the problem with AIDS
and cancer is I don't have that
[__] I got parkon
[__] I man I I I don't think he
ever put it on a special I don't know if
he ever I I don't I've never seen that
joke other than live at the Boston
Comedy Club but I remember but it's the
same thing it's just
but it you get it you get it if you had
that
platform I mean you get I totally get it
it is again it's really not the person's
doing it it's the reaction to it it's
like so then so then let's let's pull it
back for two seconds and go all right
not to not to like say we all
agree like my point is like when you
give an inch you got to get be willing
to give up the mile also so like if we
said to everyone going all right let's
get rid of SeaWorld let's get rid of
zoos get rid of Bush Gardens we'll make
natural habitats in this country where
these animals can live and they have a
great life and uh and then at what point
do you go hey by the way someone's going
to say hey no more dogs you're not
allowed of a dog like no more cats you
can't I don't want like come down and
you're like and you and then you go well
my dog lives a really great life yeah
but you're its master who the [__] do
you think you are have you ever seen it
in a field open allowed to go away I bet
my dog would love a field your dog's
name isn't even what you think it is my
dog doesn't I mean I I love my dog but
like I can't imagine they're really
through the roof happy about this small
backyard they didn't have a choice in
that yeah but I mean you're you're
absolutely right though that like you
pull that thread eventually that's what
happens that kind of has been what
that's kind of what our society is at
this point is like you know the constant
figuring out of like what is the
acceptable level but I know for a fact
like my cat doesn't want to go outside
you know I am
100% I've took him outside and he was
like buddy we got it all up there what
the [__] are we doing there's cars out
here I don't give a [__] about the
flowers IED a girl who asked me to go on
hi with her and she brought her cat
what it can wait wait wait no heads up
no head oh my God like I was like I am
breaking up with her immediately she may
as well [__] in the hotel room can you
imagine taking a cat on a walk in Ran
Canyon why the [__] first of all every
dog is like holy [__] [__] we could not
get up you know that first quarter where
couldn't even get past that I was like I
was like yeah this is over I'm going to
go for a hike I'm going to get a workout
good luck
you and your cat have a good life who
the [__] walks a cat you would walk a
cat in running can well uh I would not
without a heads up and never with like a
serious look like I would never be like
okay we've heard the joke I'd be like
let's keep going this cat's walking up a
mountain when I when I had a cat and
when I first moved here I had a cat and
I tried to take it I I was like I wonder
if it would like to go outside and so I
put it on like a little leash and I put
it and it just lowered down to the floor
and just sat there it's like I'm not
moving moving well yeah my I live near
Dodger Stadium my cat like got to the
stairs and I was like he's never seen
stairs he was like what the [__] is the
floor I was like oh God this is not
going to be an easy Journey oh the
floor's disappearing and then he sees
and then he sees rocks and flowers and
here's cars that is a great joke I love
that he's never seen stair yeah yeah why
would he he and he I mean he was
genuinely like well we better turn
around I don't think this is going to
work out for either one of us him it's
like being mushrooms like what the [__]
is happening out here by the way yeah we
had Marine World near where I where I
lived that was our one in the north been
there uh and in high school we went
there on a trip and me and a buddy took
mushrooms yeah so high school trip and
at one point that can't be good at one
point I'm sitting there and we're
looking at the Dolphins and uh and me
and my buddy are just [__] staring at
the Dolphins and you know the whole
class is there and then we're just
staring and all of a sudden a girl comes
over and tabs us on the shoulder and
she's like hey we've been gone for 20
minutes I'm like
okay I thought the dolphin said that man
wa wait what's the what's the place in I
want to say at San Francisco it's a
theme park it might be Marine World I
did an episode there it's near San
Francisco and they have white
lions oh [__] that might be Marine I
don't know that might be Marine World
might be Marine World so we do a show
with white lions and what do you mean
you do a show white tigers white tigers
a white TIG what do you mean you do a
show do a TV show just uh like doing
rides and we're [__] around but we do
a segment with white tigers and uh
aren't they super [__] rare like yes
did s freed and
Roy uh you think that would have put the
end of everything with that right yeah
really [__] up is he dead now I think
he's a I mean they yeah talk about a
disappearing act you don't hear about
those two anymore I don't I mean dis I
real like that was it you know what I
mean it was like yeah we're good we had
a run of 10,000 shows without an actual
attack
um Sig freed he's done uh let's just say
he's done that thing [__] him up
[__] him up I've I've worked with
everything and if you were at the show
somebody must have been like boy they're
really Reinventing themselves huh oh wow
this is real I want to see how he gets
up after oh it's a real Attack oh my God
I feel nauseous I uh oh man wouldn't
that have been the best show to be at
though on mushrooms you're there with
your buddy oh bad night bad night it
would have been really like I always say
that like there's two types of people
there's people that look at planes
flying in the sky and go oh I want to
travel and then there's people like me
that go I wonder if it's going to
explode yeah I always think I always
going a plan like a man it be weird to
see one of those things crash really
explode right there just like shut the
[__] I always I did that with my
mind you look at the next one honey I'm
a government weapon oh anyway we did
this thing with white tigers and they
were like H we've had a lot of fun bur
can you do the re so I turn around to do
the read and I turn my back on the tiger
and it attacks me oh [__] it attacks
well that's on you you don't turn your
back on a tiger you disrespecting
[__] no [__] but it it attack
there's a cage I should clarify there's
a cage and a pool of water in between us
uh so I'm I'm like messing with the
tiger I'm playing with it we're all like
I'm there's a cage in between us and a
big pool of water and I just turned my
back and immediately my wife watched it
and it hunkered down
creeped and left at the cage to kill me
oh my God and got onto the cage splashed
me I got covered in water but leapt onto
the cage it would have killed me in a
[__] heartbeat and they were like you
don't ever turn your back on a tiger and
you know did you know that that in India
they have masks that they wear on the
back of their heads when they walk
through oh that's why they do that yeah
so that Tigers don't attack
them I had no idea yeah whoa I didn't
even know about the mask thing dude we
went through I've just seen like
pictures of it didn't understand what
was happening we went through Vietnam
they have tigers in Vietnam and they're
like they're like if if uh you see a
tiger face it you never turn your back
on a tiger can you wink at him be like I
woke up my daughter one time we were in
uh we were in uh Hawaii we were in Maui
and work and I traveling [__] I
travel a lot and uh and so I'm getting
ready I had to leave that day to go to
DC to do a show at the DC Improv I had
to leave at noon was when my car was
picking me up and so uh it's like 6:00
in the morning and isa's my C the
daughter with a flyball and I go uh hey
we're in bed together I go hey let's
wake up let's go snorkeling let's go
snorkeling the sun's coming up let's go
snorkeling and she goes leave me alone
and I go hey I go I got to leave at noon
today let's me and you get up right now
we'll go down we'll find a sea turtle
we'll follow it around just me and you
don't tell Mom don't tell Georgia just
me and you and she looks at me in the
eyes rolls over looks me in the eyes
goes you're tugging on a tiger's tail
right
now like [__] I was like holy [__] okay
all right all right that's that's a good
description tugging on a tiger's tail
well okay that yeah now now now that I
fought tigers can I just say there's
[__] nothing better than swimming
with
turtles is it the best man and and and
this goes back I think maybe to the what
we're all saying about like uh animals
being free it really is an a real
magical moment when you're sharing a
habitat animal and you're just being hey
man I just want to chill yeah gaining an
animal's trust in that in that situation
you're like yeah it it does you're like
good I'm glad I'm glad that this
happened I picked it we went to when we
were in uh Australia we where did you go
in Australia Sydney all over we were uh
we went everywhere oh you guys did a
tour there we done a couple have we went
two tours there are you serious yeah
yeah we've got we got a really big
audience down there how Siri just popped
up she was like sir
I don't even remember that question you
austral I love it's amazing Australia's
the best man and we went to uh this
place called rotness Island it's called
Uh which the name is gorgeous but it's
basically a place where quaas uh
habitate quaca which are like I'll show
them a picture what I think I know what
you're talking about they're these
little marsupial Ador they honestly look
like uh Alvin and the Chipmunks if you
were to bring them into real life yeah
and so they're these cute little things
but they're real skittish so you always
try to get like selfies with them and
it's it really like now the island is
kind of stupid because it's a bunch of
people just on their hands and knees
trying to get the right picture so they
can [__] off but there's one like we
walked around for a while and then there
was just one that we walked up to right
when we were leaving oh my God wish
picture they run away uh and this one
he's letting me like pet his head and
he's just sort of chilling and his
buddies are kind of like hey but chill
what are you you okay Clark and I'm just
kind of rubbing his head and I start
rubbing his his back and then he starts
kind of falling asleep on my finger a
little like I have my other hand under
his chin he's falling asleep and and so
Dave's getting pictures and Dave's like
can I swap in and I'm like let's give it
a whir you know so we kind of tried to
Indiana Jones it yeah oh my God it's the
look like Alvin in the chip [__]
crazy but they're big and they're just
so he's got his he's he's got his hand
on it and I'm like I'm going to try to
pick this dude up and uh and so Dave
lets it go and I just like in a moment
of just like let's go for it I pick up
this little thing and I have him in my
arms and he's starting to sleep and
these people are walking by these
Australian people they're like I've
never seen anything like that before you
know do you know that qu and uh and it
was this [__] amazing moment and I
kept talking about it I was like this is
crazy you know like that feeling that
connection and also validating that
animal's trust and then we go to the
cafeteria cuz we have like 4 hours to
kill beer having a meal and we go up we
order and I'm just euphoric and I go to
this lady I go you know I just picked up
a quaca and I held it in my arms for
like 20 minutes and fell asleep and she
goes quka they're riddled with disease I
was like my God what salmona salmonella
and cyia I was like sorry I thought that
I'm sorry what was the last part and
then I was washing my arms in the
bathroom like a goddamn surgeon he
washed himself like 12 times I took my
shirt off I did I took my shirt off and
I wore only my sweater cuz I was and and
then like the next half of the day was
me just waiting to take this fairy back
so that I could just shower camia and
sell Manila off
me disase they're riddled with
disease they're riddled with
disease it was amazing what a great
moment it was I was busting
gushing how great is that it was amazing
oh I'm [__] crying right now really
ran the spectrum of emotion in like 15
minutes I was like I just held I'm dying
what ma'am I love the thing I love about
Australia is that like uh their racism
is like just regular it's like matter of
fact like one of the one of the things
that we that my crew found very racist
is that all the uh all the all the signs
are written for Dangerous [__] are
written in English and in German right
because Germans die at an alarming rate
AAL and they were just like they were
just like we need to we're losing a lot
of Germans
why does the sign out it's like
crocodiles in German crocodiles [__]
face stop jumping off these Cliffs
there's crocodiles in here it oh I love
it it's just very matter of fact like
listen we're losing German all right you
know what it sounds crazy put German
translations under everything I I I said
to the I we had a guide with us and I go
uh I go how come all the signs are
written in German too and they're like
oh Germans die all the time here I are
you serious go yeah you know the most
endangered species is a German here we
got a little area where they can roam
freely we lose half the Germans how
crazy is that though like but but did
you have you guys been to I think it's
called
KH uh no I don't think so it's like the
uh top the top of Australia oh no we
gone up to the top dude that's where
crocodiles are hardcore oh really yeah
like they they said to us they're like
don't go to the beach at night cuz
you'll literally be walking and then a
crocodile just eat you h uh [__]
Australia's terrifying that way oh like
animal and Bug wise Australia is like
like the stuff and I mean yeah knock on
wood but like the spiders this isn't
wood is it the spiders this is what
metal I'll find wood later are [__]
crazy and they're like comfortable with
it they're like oh that's I saw this
video of someone flushing their toilet
before they went to the toilet and like
halfway through the flush this monster
just as like in the like a thing that
would like clog your toilet like is just
swimming in it I was like oh God they've
got I think 10 of the world's 20
deadliest snakes in Australia no it's
it's all it's all things poisonous down
there it's really insane that that like
it almost like makes a reason of why
Australians are such big badasses is
like they've just survived yeah totally
great whites crocodiles poison steak
spiders I'll tell you my and I love
Australia but I'll tell you what I
really love is New Zealand we haven't
been we're going there next s wait so is
uh like you guys go there and do like
live podcast and stuff yeah we tour the
podcast there yeah the last time we went
there like in [__] Australia how do I
get to Australia we did a we sold out a
1600 SE theater and doing what
yeah anyone to anyone listening I don't
think they they understand the weight of
that that's a big really big [__] play
[__] theater the Stones played at
yeah are you serious yeah and we did
Jumping Jack Flash better I said it so
wait so you guys fly down and then you
do like a run of shows we would go we
would do for the I mean basically a city
a day or every other day and we would
just fly and we were just flying and
hitting you know venue after venue over
there did you guys hit like uh four five
no we sevenish maybe seven I think maybe
more maybe um that
is it's awesome that is the coolest
thing I've I think I've ever heard
especially about podcasting in general
oh my God is that is that that is the
coolest thing I've ever heard it's
really I mean you know as you know but
there
is yeah it's super weird and amazing
like like any of this [__] is but it is
one of those things where you you know
you are sitting there going like you
know this is really [__] crazy so I
mean it's you know a madeup thing the
way it happened was I so I did used to
do the podcast with Greg Baron yeah and
this do you know Will
Anderson I don't
know I'm sure I do I apologize will if I
don't but I'm just I'm drunk so so yeah
he's an Australian comic oh yeah I know
who he is yeah yeah yeah so um so he he
does a podcast with his friend and
someone was like who listened to both of
them was like there's an Australian
podcast like your guys and we started
listening to each other's podcast then
and then we started like communicating
on Twitter and then they came here and
we we had them on and then we I just
became I became pretty good friends with
Will and then Will's uh friend got
booked on a TV show that's very
wholesome and they didn't want him to do
the podcast cuz it was kind of dirty so
I would fill in a lot so I and at the at
the point I didn't know how big will was
but we went down to do our old podcast
walk in the room in Australia because
our numbers started going up because of
Will and when I got there I was like oh
he's a huge star yeah that's what that
is a test to the man that he doesn't
tell you that the coolest thing about
americ oh my God it's the coolest thing
about being an American comic is
sometimes you'll get into a DM with
someone you're like yeah cool man let's
hang out you're like oh [__] you're
[__] oh yeah you're the son of a Duke
yeah yeah yeah I'm doing a I'm doing a
podcast hopefully I'm doing this podcast
they like hit me up and they're like I'm
going when I go to London they're like
check out this guy Al Murray do you know
who he is yeah I and I watched him I was
like it's he's funny as [__] that's all
I watched is I was like just watch the
video didn't look at the number of it I
was like this guy's funny as [__] and so
I just DM him I go hey man I'll be in uh
London I want to do a podcast definitely
I think you're funny as [__] and he
doesn't answer for like a couple days
then I was like H [__] that's not going
to work out and then someone's like has
he and I answered and I was like oh I
haven't heard from him and they're like
oh we need to make this happen and then
I Wikipedia him huge this guy's like
[__] massive really it's like Jimmy
Carr you know Tom SC and I are sitting
backstage and Jimmy Carr comes back
we're [__] around talking to him and
we're like yeah he's a nice guy whatever
and then we go back and Tom he's like
whoa have you seen his net worth oh no
he's huge huge and and and we were like
we thought he was funny but like what
the [__] and and then we're like why did
he come backstage with us yeah then you
feel bad about we barrassed ourselves in
front of Jimmy car I wish we could have
known that he was going to be so [__]
famous we would have been cooler well he
in England my my mom lives in he's
massive oh he's massive I mean he's like
yeah he's the guy he's the guy yeah he
it would be the equivalent of like I'm
going to say Louis CK that's probably
inaccurate like Louis CK coming back and
hanging out backstage with you and then
and blowing him off yeah being like yeah
it's good man all right yeah yeah cute
anyway whatever all right we're in the
middle of Australia so oh so we go down
there and me Greg and we have will on is
this when Greg got stomach cancer no
this was the time before that okay so we
go down to do our podcast and we sold
out we decided to do a a last minute
combo podcast with the two of our
podcast together and we sold that out in
like 6 minutes it was like 300 seats and
and I was like what's happening and we
did a show that night and we walked off
and I looked at the other guys and I was
like I was like so that was the best
thing I've ever done and they're like
yeah me too like we all agreed like like
you were talking about earlier you just
have this moment where you're like
that's the [__] most amazing thing
I've ever been part of but but yeah but
you shared it with people that all
agreed on it like we did the end of the
world podcast and I got off stage and go
that's the greatest thing I've ever done
and everyone was like yeah that was fun
and I was like no can we all do this
again ever again
and Burr and Stan hope and Rogan are
like yeah we'll hit up and I was like oh
[__] I literally there was a point when
I was on that podcast and I was like I
don't know if I belong here like but
then but that that is [__] amazing
okay so we do that and then uh and then
I'm still doing walking in the room but
then I I just got tired of [__]
talking about myself so we started doing
a podcast together this the dollop and
the difference between the dollop and
walk in the room is so I have this I
have this following down there now but
the walking the room people couldn't
tell the people about it because it was
so [__] dirty that people were like I
don't know if I want to tell my friends
about this or my family but the dollop
everyone can tell everybody about CU
that's not offensive so it just you guys
realize that you were at the the the
beginning of the turn for podcasting it
feels that way because
because uh well you are too you know
you're a podcaster right no no no but I
am uh I'm the Old Guard the
conversational yeah I know what you mean
sucks I wish I wish that I I wish that I
had thought forward like but the reason
is and I say this like the cool thing is
I can I can borrow from your talent you
know like I don't have to like it's it's
got to be stressful for you guys to like
every week you got to do the work you
got to show up you do the work same
thing with Burr um I'm that old like
like a hybrid of like Rogan Marin kind
of podcast where it's very guest
specific yeah so like so like this will
be a big podcast for me but I would say
I would say the the difference is is I
think that I think that you because
you're because you're an established
comic so you have this audience but also
like your podcast is is already big I
would say the
people that that are going to get left
behind the people that now try to come
in and start a conversational podcast
like you're already established with
your conversation it's very hard to do
what I'm doing now as a podcast however
um however I believe that the the the
turn like I listened to uh Karen kilger
oh yeah Karen and Georgia Georgia was
the best part of this whole [__]
story of this the two is my oldest
daughter's name is Georgia uh oh really
and I yeah and I got a email from Brian
baldinger and he was like hey I I'm
dyslexic so I don't I don't read super
great so like uh it just said Georgia
murder and that's all I oh my God and I
went huh Georgia has been murdered oh my
God oh my God oh my God somebody read
this to me but but that podcast is a
fantastic podcast it's a reason like I
don't have a problem promoting [__] I
like like when I listen to y'all's
podcast I was like I said it I literally
I want to say three podcast in a row I
was like this is the podcast you have to
check out because it's that it's that
turn of the corner where it's
like every episode's [__] great like
they're all great they're not like I've
had some mediocre podcasts and and cuz
I'm in a bad mood or I'm not oh yeah
when your conversation but there's been
times we've done not great ones I think
yeah I think well I mean it's all
relative to the other thing is is like
we we can always fall back on the story
the story if the story is interesting
the comedy doesn't matter as much you
know what I mean yeah yeah I don't know
I I I mean I I feel like uh
you guys have the production of a
television show meaning like you guys
pretty you guys have a television show
that it's it's it it could you could go
anywhere with your show like yeah yeah I
mean it is uh yeah it is I mean and
truly the way it came about was just
very organic I mean it was like it
wasn't a thing where we planned that I
wouldn't know [__] and Dave would
explain it to me it was just you know
what happened it wasn't even going to be
I had an idea I had an idea to do this
with a different comic every week and I
brought so so when I the first time I
did it with him I I had already this
audience in Australia and and from
walking the room so the first time I did
it with him I just I was like did the
first one together cuz he was so [__]
funny on tripley show I was like I want
to do it to him first and all all my
fans were like that's the show don't get
rid of that guy that's the [__] guy I
was like yeah no he's [__] great and
then I just was like that's the show but
it that but it is I mean and then and
that it happened [__] so randomly and
then I mean which a lot of times is how
you know very interesting things happen
but it really was there was no there was
just no predetermined [__] we just sat
down and we started talking about a
topic and then slowly over the first
like Eight Episodes they were like oh
well I mean I don't know [__] about
history you love it you know I won't
don't tell me what we're going to do
before we do it let's just go the uh we
did a a podcast me Ari and Steve ver did
a podcast and very organically we came
up with with a podcast idea for Steve
about hear me that book where told yeah
he doesn't read so it's just Comics come
on and tell him about a book they read
That's great so great Steve still hasn't
done it but
uh but it's like those organic things
like I today on the podcast I did with
Tommy I was like I want to throw a
surprise party for Tosh where like 25 of
us show up at his house with groceries
and we knock on the door and he answers
the door and we're like surprised we're
here to hang out in your Mansion yeah
and uh and everyone's like oh that's
hilarious I'll be a part of it I don't
want to organize it like everyone's like
yeah I'll definitely do that if you want
to do that and the whole point is TSH
would not enjoy that right right right
at all like it is his nightmare it is
his worst [__] and I'm I'm talking
about we're bringing our kids we're
bringing [__] our dogs like it is and
uh and but then and then I get a [__]
call and they're like hey you being
serious about this and I was like I go
yeah I'm being dead serious about it and
they're like cuz this you know this
could be a really great idea and then I
go oh it's the organic [__] where people
go like you know it is real friends it
is real friends that would show up at
his house it would be a real reaction
it's like you know it's like uh it's
like when you watch Todd Glass and
Daniel Tosh hang out together and you go
oh they're real genuine friends and you
go oh it's organic it's that's maybe
that's why I like your podcast so much
is it's real it's yeah it's not forced
like no one cast you and then cast you
and said you guys need to do this
together can I give you some notes what
was the notes we were talking about
earlier yeah well that yeah I mean what
they give you yeah they always the
amount totally I think that we would
that's why podcasting is so [__]
great I mean it really is because as you
know as we all know you get involved in
this [__] and really when you it's
almost like the more you lose your
passion for something you know the the
more fingerprints are on it the more
that you kind of lose sight of it and
you're not sure what it is anymore and
if you like it nobody tells you [__]
with a podcast advertising is coming
around but there's still not even if
you're on a network like we're on all
things comedy together like you know
nobody ever tells any of us what our
podcasts should be what they need they
offer up opportunity and they want you
to thrive yeah that is so rare in
entertainment and because podcasting has
happened and it's so accessible and
anybody can do it it's it changes it and
it really does give you a platform to
just say whatever the [__] you want but
why is it like this uh podcast and I
think anyone listening to this can agree
like this is what I got into like the
fact that none of us have really hung
out like this yeah but I would very
candidly say we've laugh I have laughed
the hardest I've laughed in two hour for
two hours straight this is a green room
yeah yeah this is what we've been doing
for [__] ages right we've just been
kicking it and making it other laugh
this is what we [__] do it's the it's
the like the heart of the comic is like
is like we're all we like we all feel
like lucky that like that we got into
the carpool lane you know like like
there's it's the easy [__] Street
where it's just it's like we all have
the same sensibility like I know for a
fact even with like the SeaWorld [__] we
all probably have different opinions or
different views but none of us get
offended like like I don't you it is
impossible to offend me like yeah I I'm
pretty hard with I well and that's good
like the more I think the more of that
the like the if something doesn't you
you just can't go around getting
offended by everything because then when
something is offensive and needs to
change no it's the boy who cried wolf so
so nobody gives a [__] we're every
that's what Facebook is like whenever I
go through Facebook I'm never I never
leave feeling full of information I
leave feeling like I wasted 30 minutes
scrolling through articles dude because
everything therapy yeah every
like that that there's an addiction to
just scrolling and just going what's and
so you're just getting like a little bit
of every bit of outrage instead of f
like focusing in on like a a thing that
actually matters yeah you're just
getting pissed about every [__] that I
got to sign this petition or all this
[__] when when in reality there's big
issues that we all probably agree on but
we're just so fractured
because we have Micro opinions now what
what podcast the random question what
podcasts would you like to be on
together like would that what would like
what are your favorite podcast you were
like you know what be really fun is to
do this podcast together or separately
or individually but like I think you
guys are so good like together oh thanks
like yeah thanks like what what podcast
would you guys like to be on that you
guys have never done I mean I I think Ro
like we talked about but I think Rogan
would be fun I mean that to me like that
like yeah I I and I like a good amount
of podcast but to me uh the one that
I'm like focused on listening to yeah
that I really am like trying to absorb
all the it's almost like listening to a
documentary with Rogan at times and you
don't want to miss a beat of it that
that to me is one where um it's just
very informative always you know it's
either it's either funny as [__] and
informative or it's just super super
informative and's did you hear the one
with boss Rootin yeah where you talking
about the guy put the C ball in his
mouth and they to break his teeth off
what dude oh my God boss Rootin podcast
with Rogan is the best podcast that new
one is the best podcast I've ever heard
the one with him and K is great but like
the [__] boss Rootin is a [__]
beast the
um the thing I say about always say
about Rogan and I I'm sure I've told him
this if I haven't then I'm saying it now
when Chris Rock did his first special
the the one that changed his career uh
Cornell Wallace Cornell West Corell West
uh invited him to have dinner with him
every Sunday night wow and he said I I
think you're a really great voice in
comedy and I think in order to do that
you should be hanging out with the most
Brilliant Minds we do this dinner it's
like a Sunday conversation where it's
just the greatest Minds come to my house
we have dinner I'd like to invite you so
for like I a year Chris Ro crazy just
hung out with these Brilliant Minds and
he said he didn't speak he just listened
right and uh and I and he maybe I
thought this I'm sure he didn't say this
but it he felt it turned him into a
renaissance man
like really just listening to great
minds dude that is what [__] Rogan's
doing yeah is he takes anything he's
interested in anything that's opposing
anything that's like in his angle
Fighters Comics nutritionalist
everything he's just like bring it all
in and he drinks it in he is without a
doubt and I always told him I was like
you're different than everyone else like
I'm the same if you think you're
different you're out of your [__]
mind I'm like I think I'm [__]
different and but he is like I like if
you don't think you're different then
what the [__] do I
[__] yeah A lot's going on over here
right now Joe I got that Mickey manal
jeene come on Joe and so but like that I
I feel like a better person listen to
that podcast I would love to hear you
guys on Rog it makes I think it there
there's times when you walk when I walk
away from it and I'm like I'm going to
do that I'm going to try this I'm going
to think about this I'm going to watch
more on this person the thing about I'm
going to learn about Vim Hoff even if
even if you don't agreeing even if you
don't agree with it it still makes you
think about stuff yeah yeah you know
which which is not what you get from a
lot of podcast you're saying too you
know when he he'll bring on you know
people who I fundamentally disagree with
on so much [__] but it's it's you can
never it's better to hear the context of
why someone thinks that over just judge
their thoughts that is the [__] I wish I
didn't step on what you said because
that is the most brilliant [__]
statement i' rather what say it again
you you want to you want to know the
context of the thoughts not just the
thought so why so when someone says to
you I'm opposed to gay marriage I don't
agree with you I think that's wrong I
think everybody should be married but
instead of just shutting that down why
do you think that oh well that's
interesting I'd never heard of this guy
I'd never heard of this [__] well that
formed your opinion and now instead of
just fundamentally like getting pissed
at you we can have a conversation he has
these conversations that give you the
backstory behind beliefs it really is uh
it really is I mean I no one everyone
listen to this already Knows It But like
I would love to hear you guys on
Rogan love to hear you guys on Rogan I
would love to there's a lot of podcasts
you two have such a great energy
together like uh it's the
cocaine [__] I wish cocain I wish I
wish I wish I have high blood pressure
we where we where a point right now
where I'll ask you do we wrap this up or
do I piss and make another cocktail and
we do another 45 minutes up to you d I
can stick I'm fine all right all right
uh let's PA yeah let's piss either you
don't want a cocktail or I'm good maybe
I should stop
it thank you thank you so I'm back
recording so by the way Dave I'm going
to tell you this this Tulsa book I
bought because of uh oh shut up you
vape it's cuz he he Vapes cuz he used to
smoke it's a his way what like what what
do what what is that is that coton candy
I don't even know what it is I just have
a buddy who gives I uh here you got a
connection for your
Vapes it's candy of some nature it does
smell like cotton candy it's cotton
candy you're a [__] 37y old man
smoking cotton candy look dreams really
do come
true dud you told me I could smoke
cotton candy as a kid I mean honestly I
was thinking that earlier I what I was
thinking of earlier was if emissions
like this car was in front of me and it
was just juicing me with like black
smoke and I you know one of those cars
that shouldn't have passed the missions
and I was like if that smelled like
candy but I'd be less rubbed but you
know what's crazy is that in a weird way
cotton candy is going to smell like
poison to Children yeah right they're
going to go oh it's Vape oh that's so
weird yeah [__] up we knew smelled like
like cuz we were like oh that's [__]
fumes and then one day our kids will
smell cot and K and be like oh gross
I'm not e Vape how long have you been
vaping uh like about a year and a half
just smoked cigarettes right no I don't
think there's cigarettes make me sick do
you feel healthier now yeah and I don't
I like I you know I don't use it like
crazily like cigarettes you hav't it's
been yeah it's been two and a half hours
and I'm like embarrassed by it I feel
like shame with it as as I should it's
such a it's like a it looks like a weird
yeah like VAP no it's it's [__]
stupid it's stupid and if you ever want
to have an amazingly weird experience
and feel like you're in the Fifth
Element go into a vape store because
they they encourage like chilling out
and like you know like vaping with each
other hanging at The Vape hanging at The
Vape but I went in there I a buddy
honestly a buddy sounds like a theater
in San Francisco you guys have to go to
The Vape they do amazing gorilla theater
at The Vape you must hit that but like
there were these dudes uh competing over
blowing smoke rings [__] off and it was
like the uh I saw this online I saw it
was like the hardest 2 minutes and 30
seconds like waiting for your debit to
clear I've ever had I was like hurry I
don't want to catch douche shut up yeah
it was amazing so one night we're in uh
at some
casino and uh the guy goes uh they're
giving out free cigarettes uh the
cigarette pens oh and then I go why
wouldn't I introduce a little nicotine
into my life tonight sure yeah yeah what
is this going to hurt what what who it's
it's not a why would they be given away
for free just just awesome and nice of
them it's not like are they fairies yeah
do they have wings and I started hitting
it and I could not breathe in the middle
of the night like as sleep I woke up in
the middle of the night and I could not
breathe and I went holy [__] like I I
mean wow yeah well to me like when I
would and this is I I'm not advocating
pro vaping but personally with s like I
would never be on record as that get get
that my bumper wait uh why I'm going to
get him a shirt that says Pro Vape Pro
Vape I love Vape
jokes talk to me about vaping Vape
culture kills me man Vape
culture this bro comedy's killing Vape
culture oh no Vape isn't funny Vape is
not
funny I got date Vaped one
time I don't want to hit come on before
I drop you off no I had a lovely evening
I said no take one hit oh it's like take
a hit man it's like cotton candy what's
the big deal yeah it's free but yeah
like I I I would feel like sick the next
day if I smoked cigarettes right now
like they make yeah they make me feel
sick like I I miss cigarettes so much oh
dude me and my buddy talk about it all
the time like if you when we have this
moment where I turn on the news and
someone's going to you're going to see
the footage of the meteor and the
president talking someone's going to say
can you believe that to me and see me
across the street buying maror mediums
like the first thing I'll do and then
I'll be back I'll be like it's crazy I'm
going smoke them two at a time when did
you start smoking young like I probably
had my first cigarette when I was
probably like 10 what yeah or 11 Fu
because my family's English and my
cousin who was like my best friend was a
year older but they do everything they
do born in England I was born in
Wisconsin but raised by English people
the English start doing everything way
to like let's start [__] we're 11 I
I'm not kidding you when I went to
England one time know you hate poor
white
people and which is what my family is
I'm gonna say that might be a lot of
Florida well a lot of Florida yeah poor
[__] Tong this Joe never has eaten
[__] never he's never eaten
[__] yeah never I mean he might have
it's the only time someone said less
teeth when someone's gone down on him
and it's a female I never thought I'd
say this honey less teeth BR less teeth
it's God did you come can you come oh
boy wait this is a real person who will
definitely be listening to this is that
okay a real human being is going to be
mad no what you going to say to me
nothing [__] man like this is like this
has been the most seamless podcast I've
ever [__] done shut up I've serious
like it's podcasts like this that make
you go oh this is why you podcast yeah
there is that's like he was talking
about Will Anderson before like that's
how I really met like will too was like
talking through a microphone so you sort
of you start your relationship or your
your friendship with someone like
talking and recording it it's pretty
weird and interesting there's a lot of
people where I go like Owen Benjamin I
only know Owen basically I we've hung
out it before but like really is
podcasting like when you come over Shane
Moss like just doing like a 2hour three
hour podcast with him and you're like
like Owen did the first time he did my
podcast I was blown away at how
untethered he was he is unte that's a
good word for Owen and he's and he's
very he's very smart like I I'd almost
argue autistic like he was raised by
very intelligent teachers like he is so
he's like a master of debate he really
is he's very good at Devil's advocating
things and making you go I get it like
that yeah uh but like Shane Moss another
guy yeah yeah one of the things that I
hated about this Dave you I think you've
probably been on both sides of this is
that we got split up in comedy with this
alt and and I guess bro comic I guess is
what You' say but I don't think that any
of us are that right but the extremes of
us made the fence yeah I totally agree
that's true like the extremes of us the
guys that had no act that couldn't do an
ALT room and be conversational [__]
hated the AL guys and the all people who
aren't fun funny and and couldn't cross
over [__] hated the Bros but it was
like this it was it was like and it's
like I mean like you don't say anything
but I'll say handedly I think I watched
uh Jen Kirkman special I [__] loved
it I haven't seen it yet Jen would be
someone that we would consider
Al fantastic and I talked to another
quote unquote bro comic who was like I
[__] loved her special really yeah
she's yeah I mean I have she's been
working it hard for [__] a few years
do and I and I will say this and I hope
that she hears this she looked
absolutely gorgeous that is a sidebar to
this yeah but like so gorgeous and
special and I was like I was like God
damn it man like how [__] how cool
for her to go up murder and be Gorge
like I'm just fat that's all I'll get
stuck with no no you're you have your
own sort of pretty think than go plus
you sound like a [__] horse which is
super cool I can do really good horse
Impressions it's like
chicken you guys seen horse it just
murdered Montreal 6 Figure deal oh
welcome to the
barn yeah but like there's a lot of like
it stinks because it's there a lot of
really great comics on both sides of the
fence that and you just work different
clubs you know like I think UCB is a fun
Club to do I'll tell you what one of my
favorite places in the world to work
that I don't work at all is melt toown
yeah that's fun love that place yeah
every time I've done a show there I've
enjoyed it so great the stores I would I
think anyone could argue on but the
store is the greatest place to do comedy
right now in the world still not gone to
the store I've done a couple sets there
but I've never one last time every time
I tried to get in there they've been
like it's just a lot of [__] people
even when I was on MAR I was like now I
could try and get in there yeah me to I
was I was there I was like that for a
while uh and they were like you know I
think Bill and and Al tried to get me
ped I I've tried to get pasted like
probably five times there for shut up
are you not P there I'm past you are
yeah okay but like it was just one of
those things that I was like it was a
couple things that I one one I was
talking to my therapist I was like I
really want to work the store and he was
like you know just so you know if if you
want to work the store that means you
have to work the store that means you
have to show up there you have to be
there you have to work the store you
can't just go I work the store but not
go there yeah and I was like oh I never
thought about about it that way and uh
and I just was like that's right and
then I was like you know what I got to
put my ego aside and I've got to do
whatever spots they offer me and just be
around a lot and and and it's what I
like to do anyway but it in a weird way
it was [__] with my ego like it was
making me feel less I think that is when
I before Adam uh was there the greatest
thing that ever happened to the store
the greatest thing that ever happened to
the store no questions out other than
Mitsy Shore who obviously is the
precursor to this Adam well cuz he I
mean and the proof is in the way the
store has had this huge Resurgence I
mean it's just very evid every show yeah
that since he's been there every show
sells out it's an Instagram I follow
that always makes me go like it looks
like everyone's having a lot of fun over
there because it really is when you're
on the road and you look at that you're
like wow shut so you're telling me that
you just put on a
$240,000 show yeah technically for
nothing oh yeah that's crazy Rogan deia
Bur Paul [__] uh David Spade Ron
White that I'm sorry that was your
lineup yeah that's crazy J Appel Daniel
Tosh Tom seura [__] shut do you Mur
do you realize the [__] I mean I
everyone realizes it but
that they the the price point on that
show is through the [__] I've never
actually thought of it like that but
that is CRA it really is a testament to
what it's like in LA to be a [__]
comic I mean that that like how how does
so how do you make the argument that you
belong on those lineups I don't I can't
you can't I go hey thank you for having
me on I really appreciate this anytime
I'm on those shows I go shut up Andrew
Dice Clay Roseanne Bar Lou Lou CK yeah
are you [__] kidding me these are
people that I know what I know what I
can tell you what Tom sgura makes and I
can tell you that you couldn't get that
lineup yeah I mean they'd be selling
stadiums I know yeah it's crazy and and
these are people who were trying to get
or asking for these spots yeah want to
perform there Dave Chappelle ask and and
and you go wow yeah like I I mean I've
run into so many people that are like
hey I'm going to La I'm going to the
store so many people yeah like really oh
my God the majority of people that are
at the store in my opinion these days
are people flying in from different
states to see comedy wow it is like yeah
it's really it's a I'm very very
grateful
that that unpassed me but I but like
even
still I can't like like I had a DAT
where I got P I got bumped by Jud appow
and Daniel Tosh and Louise yeah and
everyone's like hey man I'm sorry I was
like you do not have to stay sorry to me
you saw those names right I get it like
I am [__] well aware of where I am in
my career I'm the guy that's willing to
stick around till 1:00 to get on they
all got other [__] to do like yeah but
like you know that's the coolest thing
about the store is is just that you know
but I don't know what but I don't know
what my whole point was but you've been
on both sides of the fence I think yeah
on all sides of the fence I think I was
always you know I did both things you
know I've always sort of done that yeah
I've I've never understood the it's
you're definitely right there's dudes
who can't do both and those are the ones
who can't but Mo most Comics can adopt
adapt to both those rooms and work them
both and do it and it's fine like the
vast majority when you first are like
like you hear alt room and you're like
what is that I I was just like what does
that even mean like it took me a minute
to understand that it you can adapt your
material you know what I mean like you
think of it is almost this crazy thing
and it really
isn't you got to lose as a bro comic for
sure to do all like you can't say fat
you're aware yeah yeah well there are
some guys that are completely unaware
yeah yes there are there absolutely are
it could be argued I might be one of
those
guys I've definitely said things in in
at the UCB that I was like maybe I
shouldn't have said
that technically technically all right
yeah all right what do you want out of
me I remember Pete Pete Holmes I said
fat chick at UCB and Pete Holmes like
you know it's like saying
negro and I was like I was like really
he goes yeah yeah yeah like very [__]
aggressive the best part of this whole
argument and I love Pete obviously but
the best part of this argument was he
was like you can't say fat chick I go I
I still [__] one and he goes no what and
he goes and he goes you can't say that
you say uh the best thing about having
sex with a girl with a little more
milkshake is the breakfast in the
morning I go no one sticks around I
[__] love Pete I love Pete he's like
you know B baby I just can't reach you
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I am not that guy I I'm so bad at
[__] sometimes I'm super bad yeah
like I just go what I'm the [__] I'm
the gorilla in the cage but you're being
H I mean you know I to me I'm like if
someone is being honest that's their
right to be you know I don't know
there's just something very strange
about the idea that uh you know language
is monitored so I there was when we when
I was in New York when we were in New
York at the same time I guess right I
was there in '96 to 2000 yeah we're
there same time so I must we must have
[__] seen each other all remember guy
Nam Doug s yeah okay so Doug s was I'm
saying I think I'm saying his name right
I think he's I'm almost certain he used
to tour with Robert uh Shimmel okay very
funny comic but like hardcore Boston
salty like right real like and this is
what I love about comedy you couldn't
shake it out of him right so he's on
stage at the Boston comedy club and
there's four black chicks in the front
row oh they're [__] they're uh [__]
kind of [__] with them making fun
with them and he's like what and they're
like
uh oh you couldn't handle us and just
without realizing what he said he goes
ah I always wanted to [__] a colored
chick the place loses their [__] mind
and he goes he goes what what in a good
way like I want to [__] col he didn't
realized that what he was saying was he
thought he was like what no I'm very
Progressive bab the colored ones are the
ones I want I'm excited to be with one
it was I mean we were [__] howling
back and then he got off he goes that
went well and I was like Doug no you
realize what you said right he was like
well no like shelto Boston like shelto
Boston [__] [__] lost my mind it's so
Boston there was a dud there was a there
was there was it was like those moments
was like like when you know you're
laughing for another reason there was a
comic I don't know this guy I'm sure
he's not doing it anymore I'm certain
he's not doing it anymore but uh he was
like hardcore Italian and someone said
something I someone said something like
uh are you from Chelsea and he goes uh
I'm not a [__] or a Mexican and
everyone oo and he goes what I'm a comic
everyone's like no you're not no I
remember that so distinctly yeah he goes
I'm not a [__] or a Mexican and
everyone was
like and he was like what I'm a comic
it's a joke and was like no I don't
think it is remember the joke part of it
uh I saw Mike Mike EPS come off stage
one time it was a remember they used to
do Sundays at the Boston Comedy Club it
was all it was all black yeah so Mike
caps comes off stage and there's oh no
Mike Mike caps is about to go on stage
and someone comes off and they bomb and
they're like this like reel in their
head like God damn like [__] [__]
[__] and Mike was not paying attention
and he turned around and the guy was
like ha and he just came at Mike wrong
and Mike just knocked him out shut the
[__] up he just called and I
went and the guy went down and Mike's
like what what what what happened and
like walked down the stairs to the bagot
in and just disappeared and I was like
holy [__] that's the worst B that's the
worst bombing you could ever have had so
much energy coming off like [__] [__]
[__] and he just caught Mike at the
wrong time Mike's like and I was like
whoa I used to party with him a lot
don't sneak up under M GS no bombing
front of mic so where did you when you
lived in New York where did where were
you working uh seller uh a lot I was
there like I followed a for like two
years uh for five nights a [__] week
was that was that he used to go on at
what like 1110 or something or I was
going on 11:30 God damn it yeah uh and
then uh I did the comics trip a lot
those two clubs mostly never did the
comics strip I is that Lucian yeah I
went up an audition for Lucian [__] and
uh he told me I didn't have what it
takes to be in the buiness business yeah
he's he was [__] he was just such a
piece of [__] did did you get you
correct me if I'm wrong my memory is so
bad but you do the audition then you go
into like a real tiny closet you go into
his office and you sit there and he
explains to you why he's not going to
past you he sits me down he
goes
well I already have a Tom
agna And I was like do you know Tom
Agnes
like the most dead pan
[__] genius comic yeah he he wrote
Conan's uh monologues for the first two
years like just [__] genius but just
dead pan joke telling and I'm like I
don't even know not I don't even know
what you're talk talking about like it
it's it was just such a crazy comparison
I was like I don't know what's happening
right now he goes so I can't pass you
I'm like wait what you have a guy that's
nothing like me so he just categorized
me this is [__] hilarious so he
categorizes me as Tom agna and I'm like
yeah [__] I don't know so I I keep
trying to get past there and I used to
hang out with Tom Papa and Ian bag a lot
we used to kick around and then uh so I
was always CU those guys were already
passed I was there a lot back when Ian
was fat what oh my favorite Ian bag when
he was fat yeah yeah yeah he was big fat
and and wore shorts all [__] winter
oh nice like just love I'm Canadian B
what it's not
cold man he's a guy you can't be around
him long enough too long because you
start adopting in the way he speaks
totally entirely totally right so uh so
I go up to Luci one day and I go hey man
I want to I want to try and get past it
and he goes you're pasted I you've been
passed for a while I'm like what are you
talking about and he goes I go you never
told me he goes no but you were just
around he never told me I was
passed so you were just for like six
months or a year and then I go up to him
go hey man I wonder if I can you know be
seen again he goes no you're
pass what the [__] is happening you have
a weird system sir he just let me out of
the closet he told me very candidly I
would not make it as a comic you are not
he did that to so many [__] people
people who then went on to be big Comics
like that was his thing he'd loved to do
that that is the that is the power that
I mean that's the it's the cult
mentality eventually you're like it's
about me Lou Schaefer told me that
you'll never make it really move back to
Tampa punch him right in the neck I was
like I was like what how did you take it
were you motiv ated by it or was it
gutting so uh I'm sure people have heard
this if they haven't it is kind of
interesting so it was my 26th birthday
and I my dad called me to tell me what a
piece of [__] I was that's a great
that's a great birthday it oddly enough
best birthday I've ever had in my life
okay my dad calls me I thought he was
wishing me happy birthday and he's like
you are a piece of [__] that was the
first words out of his mouth I was like
I go you know it's my birthday and he
was like I go I thought you were wishing
me happy birthday he was like he was
like no you're an embarrassment I'm I'm
I [__] up I really [__] up raising
you uh I'm embarrassed of you I I
perjured myself he kept saying that he
was in court that day and the judge had
said how's your son doing and my dad
said great and he goes I perjured myself
oh my God that's bruted myself what the
[__] nobody told you to perger yourself
dad Dam you could have said I was a
piece of [__] on the stand yeah I didn't
make you Pur objection your honor I
don't want to know this L of question is
aggressive I'm taking the fifth yeah I'm
taking the fifth
how's your son doing I'm taking the
fifth I play the fifth
Cas and uh and he gave me a very uh like
a real beat down verbally of like what I
was where my shortcommings were a lot of
it was humility um and and white
privilege ultimately it's a it's a it
was just White Privilege that's all it
was really and
so I said how can I fix it and he told
me go said go to the Boston compy club
and tell them you'll do anything to get
on stage and I go that's not how it
works cuz it wasn't how it worked it
really wasn't no yeah my dad's like
that's how it works if you are a poor
black kid living in Harlem that's how it
works for that guy it that's how it
works for you he goes that's how it
works for everyone everyone accepts
humility and I said all right so I went
my 26th birthday went to the club went
up to Louis schaer and I was like hey uh
I've been hanging out the club all the
all the time and I was like I want to be
a comic can you please get I'd like to
get on stage I'd like to do stand
standup comedy what can I do I'll do
anything and he said move back to
Florida and I was like okay that's and
so I I went home I I drank at the bagin
in that night or uh McDougle house went
to my apartment called my dad the next
morning I said this is what he said my
dad goes great go back tonight say the
same [__] thing and you'll do that
every single night of your life until he
gives you an opportunity yeah and I was
like okay so I went back that night I
did it again and he was like I thought I
told you to move back to Tampa and I was
like that's not an option for me I'm
going to do this every single night I'm
going to be here every single night you
need to give me an opportunity and and
he's like all right stand out front if
you can bring in 20 people I'll put you
on after Godfrey that's Louis schaer and
so I was like I get to go on after
Godfrey which by the way was a nightmare
spot yeah yeah but Karen you remember
Karen um Karen Karen Beren uhuh Karen
Beren went on I brought in these four
PTO Rican guys put them up front and
they made her cry and she it was bad
they were bad I think one guy was going
to prison and that's so New York and uh
and Lou shaver just hopped off off stage
and he was like hey no one was there
he's like you want to be a comic you're
up and I went up and I destroyed them
but it was just like probably very
borderline racist frat boy [__] but it
killed in the room and they let they
walked the room they left the room and
the place went nuts and then L is like
you got a job you can do this every
night as long as you want and then 6
months later uh you know the Will Smith
thing happened it was a really like a
real luck thing so that's that's a let
let's give another side of Lewis I don't
want people listening to think that
Lewis is a nice shot sure oh no no
uh Lewis then uh the reason I went with
uh Patrice and me Patrice Rich F and Ben
Bailey went to Scotland and in Edinburgh
with Lewis oh [__] me you did what yeah
is that where he met the chick he
married no he had met her ear earlier I
you know it's so funny I don't remember
I remember hanging out with her a lot
because she would come over and stay in
New York and hang out with ls but that
is the setup like they started dating
she managed Ed burn do you remember Ed
burn Irish comic yeah she managed Ed
burn I think that's his name Ed Burns no
that's the name of the the actor from
and writer director menen it's the same
name though I think it is it's the same
name she managed him and then she got us
into Edinburgh and then Lewis stayed he
stayed there we went to Edinburgh and he
stayed he never left he never left never
left wow I don't i' be interested to
have him on a podcast you're going to be
London that's
crazy I'm working at the seller you know
two years you know like I said and uh
and one night I'm there I going to stop
you right now you have no
idea how much I'd pay to go in a time
machine to see this story happen in real
life because knowing Dave the way I know
Dave and knowing Lewis the way I know I
can see this being [__] a mile away
epic so uh he's hosting as he did and I
I mean he's just the you know he's
[__] you can clearly see we're not
going to be two guys who got along like
I would just give him [__] all the time
you don't know any of is z do you no oh
[__] man
uh you like this this jacket oh
God it's uh Armani
is oh boy yeah the whole Louis schaer's
whole thing was Lou schaer not gay not
gay L not gay I'm not gay beautiful
chocy band beautiful chocolatey black
band not gay not gay but you maybe not
gay not gay not gay that was the whole
thing so he's hosting by the way Lou
taper does
have
does have one of the funniest moments
I've ever seen on stage in my life what
maybe two of them maybe inadvertently or
it was the what was broken about Lis
Schaefer was the best part of him yeah
so like one is Judy Gold uhhuh she's
about to bring Judy Gold on stage he
says what would you like me to say about
you I'm very very Over the Top gay but
not gay that was his whole bit she goes
what nothing you know what just don't
whatever just don't hack it up don't say
anything about my height so he goes uh
what can I say about this next lady
except for Fifi F
fum second second second one I'm G to
have to I'm G to have to I'm G to have
to edit this only because it's so
good so black guys on
stage I can't cuz I'm I'm never never
going to anyway black guy's on stage and
he's like talking about how uh white
guys can't say the ant word when a white
guy says the an word it just sounds
wrong you can't say it the way like when
I say it it sounds real it's going on
and on and on and on and on it's all
black Club Ander goes on and goes oh God
he's like all right thank you good night
and gets off stage and Louis schaer says
wow that was one funny nword like but
says the N word yeah and [__]
silent but like those were the best
moments of him is that he was not he was
not and then but then he'd come off and
he would spiral out spiral out like a
[__] crazy bad like he'd lose his
mind like one time one time when I was
working the door I got there he called
me and he goes uh I'm not going to make
it to when the show opens but I'll be
there for the beginning of the show so
can you just get the room ready and put
on some music or whatever so I bring
like a whole case of CDs and
uh like an idiot I just I just grab a
Richard prior CD and I put in Richard
PRI to play and and I'm bringing people
I'm sitting them they're [__] howling
around sure and Lou schaer comes in and
he's like listens and he goes comes
walking outside he goes how am I
supposed to follow Richard
prior I was like I never thought of that
oh that's a good point yeah he was an
interesting guy so wait I want to hear
this story I apologize it's fine so uh
so there's a guy
heckling uh the comic before me I don't
remember who it was um but but the guy
what whoever couldn't handle it and so
if you're the [__] MC you go up and
you deal with that [__] but Lewis goes
up and doesn't do [__] so now I'm like
all right I got to go up and take care
of this so I go up and I [__] shut
the guy down and then I just keep going
after him and the crowd's laughing and
yeah it's one of those deals where
everyone's annointed a [__] Heckler
and I took care of business which I
thought was his job yeah so I get off
stage and Lewis walks up and
apologizes to the
Heckler on behalf of the club oh and
me oh my God Dave you must have become
an animated cartoon and so I'm standing
back there and I'm [__] rocking and
I'm there with another comic Ray James I
know Ray oh yeah you know Ray yeah the
little little tell yeah so uh so that's
what they used to call him little little
tell so me and me and uh me and Ray we
started together in San Francisco so
we've known each other forever and uh
and we're both pretty angry guys at this
point and uh and walks off and I go what
the [__] was that and he goes what I had
to I you were you were too hard on the
guy I'm like he's a [__] Heckler we
we don't [__] apologize you don't
[__] apologize on my bad for the
close beh like I'm just going at him we
don't negotiate with terrorists yeah
yeah really [__] Li but you you
should have seen you guys faces when I
said he apologized you both were just
like oh yeah I mean
absolutely shocking move so so then we
start arguing and then him and Ry start
arguing and it gets physical like
[__] Ray like he pushes Ray Ray
[__] punches him in the chest and
then it's kind of over I like stop it
and I'm like you're just a [__] piece
of [__] Louis and we
leave and then the next day I get a
phone call from the owner Manny and he's
like uh so tell me what happened and I
go what there's the Heckler blah blah
blah and he goes and what else happened
and I go nothing else happened he goes
anybody hit anybody and I go no one hit
anybody not that I remember I didn't see
anything no one hit anybody and he goes
you're going to tell me right now you're
saying for sure that no one hit anybody
I'm like dude no one hit
anybody let it go and I'm like there's
no way this [__] piece of [__] went
and squealed to the owner so then oh boy
then all of a sudden we get a call get a
call all comics on deck and this H this
used to happen every couple of years
club meeting all past Comics have to be
at the club at 3: or 4 or something I
love that by the way yeah it's so if the
comic if Comedy Store was like Hey all
Comics need be there at noon I'd be like
oh is the bar open yeah the funniest
thing is you mean noon shows no BD noon
party BD someone's in trouble theun we
party during it the funnyest thing is
I'm walking with the tail we're walking
in together and he goes what' you do I'm
like oh god oh so we all sit down and uh
Manny goes uh
so someone in here you know there's a
situation with a Heckler and he
basically told everyone to be nicer
nicer nicer to the hecklers ah what yeah
oh was [__] crazy and then he goes uh
and somebody lied someone in here is a
liar and he calls me out he he says you
he calls me out and he goes uh you lied
to me someone hit somebody and that
person is not here because he's banned
from the club but you lied to me and the
only way you can work here again is if
you say you li Li and that you're not a
man
H which to Dave Anthony is is like being
like have some poison
soup you lied to me and you're not a man
wanted me to say I'm not a man and I
lied to you and Dave knowing you my
guess is those words didn't come out of
your mouth I just got up and walked out
and I never worked there again wow are
you serious yeah and tell was like this
he goes I've been barred from the club
everyone's been barred from the club
comes and go and he'll be back in in 6
months but I was like yeah but I'm not
going to [__] I don't give a [__] if
he wants me back I'm not going [__]
back because of what he said to me [__]
him there's there's that Anthony magic
that's that that oh and then it gets
even worse cuz I killed him cuz Manny
cuz Manny dies right and Jes every dies
in these stories and I'm on the street
with a tell in La we're in front of the
Improv and he goes you heard Manny died
I go [__] yes I did and he got so
[__] mad at me oh God yeah oh yeah
tell and Manny were close right yeah
they were close and I was like [__] yes
he did I was so [__] I give a [__]
Jesus God finally passed him I've I've
told this story before and I'll tell it
one more time because uh I I love this
story but like uh I got passed at this
Sellar by Manny uh I did a show and I
was with Marin
Marin uh Manny came up and said you
Manny's like you know this guy or
regardless I let me don't stop me in
this story okay so
uh Marin vouches for me and says I'm
funny and then I do my set I have a
really great set and Manny comes up to
me and this is and he's like hey buddy
you did a great show you can pass here
call St whenever you want I tell the
story to Pete Corelli and he goes Manny
didn't have an
accent I go really he goes yeah he
didn't have an accent at all and I was
like I could have sworn he had like who
the hell passed me I think a hobo passed
me oh you can work here and they T me to
lie I don't know BT just kept showing up
some Europeans said it was fine I was I
I was high as [__] with Pete and I tell
him the story about getting pass at the
seller like how it was one of the most
pivotal moments of my career he just
looks has an accident didn't have an
accident and I was like really Manny was
like Hey you want work here you got to
bring a
meatball what are you doing you're funny
guy first do you make a bread sticker
for two year then maybe you get a
microphone hey a wiser
guy I give him a little chip of a give a
little bite one a little shav I those
were the [__] best times of my life I
wish I could go back to being like 26
years old and hanging out at the seller
going doing Boston doing your set and
then going to sell and hanging out like
having beers with Geraldo dude we would
we would drink a [__] we the kettle
of fish you ever go there yeah of course
we SC we SC the [__] Kettle and then
we would and then we knew them so they
would close the doors and let us keep
drinking till [__] that's a run by
people from Milwaukee which explains I
wonder why we didn't party I mean we
seemed like we would been right up the
alley I'm sure we you might just
remember him with an accent it might be
that I Remember You Came me like hey
Budd hey I'm a David Anthony are you
going to meet a me back in La buty we
met her before H twirl of my mustache
hey buddy all right I had a I had a
really great moment you know I always
say ignore whatever I say because I
don't my memory is so bad but I had a
really interesting moment when I was
working the door right right before I
got my deal Jordan Ruben uh Judi Reed
ler Ben Bailey took me to
um I think it was kettlefish maybe that
was on uh on on third
right yeah took me there and they sat me
down and they bought me a beer and I was
on I was on uh antibiotics at the time
small detail and they were like uh hey
you got to stop working the door and I
was like what and they're like it's a
[__] waste of your time people are
going to see you as someone that uh
isn't a comic right and I was like
really and they're like yeah yeah you
got to stop and then I ended up moving
to LA right after that yeah but uh it
was a really you know I look back I'm
those to this day I I I like I I can
call Bobby Kelly who was you know I was
just at the door I didn't know anyone no
one was really my friend but like Bobby
Kelly was always at the door and he was
always you know hanging out I just hang
out Donell Rollins uh Juda all these
guys like I call Bobby when I have
problems and I can talk to him like a
like a friend it's a weird connection
you get when you do stand up oh totally
I said to yeah I said to my wife one
time she goes uh some show got picked up
or something and I was like she goes you
must be really proud we're driving I can
tell you where we were do you know that
uh mix martial arts uh you have to live
right around here to know this but
there's like a mixed martial arts place
on Laurel Canyon and mo Park yeah I know
what you're talking about yeah it looks
like a punching bag store
almost we're driving right by that and
my wife goes you must be really proud of
you of this and in an instant I thought
the only thing I'm proud of is the fact
that I I'm a comedian that I have a
group of guys and girls and women that
like that you can that you've earned it
with you know what I mean it's like
there is something it's a big difference
to have earned it yeah it it's it it
means something it means so much to me I
think in a way maybe why there is a
quick connection with with
Comics is because you if someone's there
you know that they've been through a lot
of [__] to do it to be there yeah and
that's almost an experience that's so
lonely in its own way at the beginning
and then maybe at the end that just
gives you an instant connection with
someone because you know that they're
suckers for pain and they've gone
through it too and you're both here to
have a good time and not the other thing
I find that's pretty amazing is that I
don't never feel very competitive with
comics on a you never on a show you
don't feel like you're never like I want
to do the you're like I did when I
started out but but eventually you're
like there's enough and it's it's the
natural you know the timing of it all
it's all very random and away I would
say I would I would and this is a weird
thing but I would credit that to a
little bit and hear me out but to Lou
and Bill and Joe and guys like in Marin
who were like hey man it's not about
murdering it's about working on new
stuff yeah there was a period of time
you guys know this period of time in LA
where it was just about murdering yeah
yeah and it was like I I remember
remember coming out here for the first
time uh and seeing DNE and going I had
never seen anyone in New York that
didn't bomb a little bit yeah I just
didn't see that and I was like he kills
every [__] time and then that became
the the the across the board it was like
everyone murders yeah and then and then
that created a laziness that does yeah
totally it was about [__] comedy like
getting [__] yeah doing comedy to get
[__] and then and then there was this
like this this move of like Louie and
Bill David tell always David tell man
and I say this in the most respectful
way in the world David tell always
bombed a little bit always because he
was always trying stuff I mean dude that
I would watch like I said I went after
him it was like he had he was trying to
new 20 minutes every [__] night
that's you remember you you'll I almost
want to say you'll guar I guarantee
you'll remember this do you remember
there was a period of time where he was
trying to figure figure out a joke about
hitting someone on the head with a
hammer yes like do you remember that
like there was a he must have worked
this joke 19 different ways and he could
NE and every time I was at the Celler
he's like you know the weird thing about
hitting someone in the head with a
hammer when you come up behind someone
with a hammer like it was always about a
hammer and I was like man this is not
[__] working almost to the point when
when I see him I go hey man you ever
figure out that
Hammerhead he always had this job and I
was like Wow but then you'd have these
moments where like it was real brilliant
I remember one time uh tell me if you
remember this time this is so
specific he was on stage and he was
getting heckled by a guy with two hooked
hands oh my God no I was I if I had a
tell's number I'd call him and I
remember just being like looking up to
the skies like how do I get out of this
and the guy was heckling him and he was
hammered and Dave's like okay you're
you're getting a pass on this one like
really I am not and my memory is [__]
but I remember that two hooked hands
he's like what are you going to say
nothing nothing I'm going to ask you to
again be quiet with sir who I
respect just take one of your never mind
yeah it uh it is such a weird the the
the ultimate David tell moment for me
was we're at the seller and he's he's on
stage he's doing his acting a woman
stands up and just starts walking to the
bathroom and he he's in the middle of a
joke and he goes save some and then goes
back to the joke like it was just such a
little aside in right there a punch line
save some it was like I [__] fell out
of my [__] chair yeah I walked maybe
five days into comedy I walk down the
Celler me and Demitri Martin Demitri
goes I'm going to go back to the back
corner table I'm going to sit down I'll
save you a spot I said I'm going to go
to the bathroom I'm wearing a Hawaiian
shirt I walk little road to the bathroom
and David tells stage and he goes and he
sees me in the Hawaiian shirt he goes
only two things wear Hawaiian shirts
[__] and party
animals my God pick which one you are
and I go I'm a party animal and he goes
man that's what I
thought
he he is geni and I have to say this I
have to say this only because I have to
say this I did uh some casino and he was
doing a show with Kevin Hart Sarah
Silverman and him was the three of them
and they sold out I want to say like
20,000 seats wow and I was doing the
club and I was maybe selling 50 75 tops
yeah and until of course before my set
comes over to like say hi yeah just like
he's got 20,000 sold out and he just
stops by to say I wasn't there and they
and he was like hey please tell bird I
came by to say hi that a good guy he's
always been the nicest guy Fu the dude
he did that when I was in New York at uh
Gotham he came in dropped in to say hi
and I was on stage and then went back to
the DJ booth and said tell bird I came
out to say hi like just and he just
knows it's I mean maybe he doesn't maybe
that's just he's a great guy but it
means so much to me like he was my hero
man like like he still is he still is
massively my hero but like I mean
obviously you look at my career I've
definitely [__] patterned it after
his like it's a clear parallel with my
drinking and his drinking and like
I it was like uh yeah what a [__]
I've want to tried to get him on my
podcast so many times but he's you know
it's like yeah amazing I mean that truly
like that that is a guy that uh you know
every comic is like that guy is
unbelievable and anybody who you show
his [__] to is like that guy is
unbelievable he just there's a lot of
guys like that you know and I'll say
this about
like you know maybe I guess maybe we
phase out the ones that suck is that how
it works yeah well yes to some extent I
mean if you're 45 years still doing
comedy chances are you're pretty good I
hope so like I mean like no but everyone
who's who's you know in their 40s and
doing comedy has earned it and is and is
funny like the not funny guys are are
gone at that point stop you know buddy
Bolton yeah he was a dick to me buddy
Bolton there were so many [__] there
were a lot of guys that were dicks that
there a lot of guys I gotten too I'll
never forget uh uh what Dane did to me
one time wait what so by the way by the
way have be careful have you seen Dane
uhuh he is yoked ripped to [__] is he
yoked yeah well I said it's a girl oh I
shouldn't say this
mind I go I don't know what's gayer
danne's photos on Instagrams or the fact
that we're tweeting him back in forth to
each
other every time Dane posts a picture me
and seura screen grab him and send them
like oh my God look at how great he
looks look at him he's beautiful [__]
all right he is [__] yoked right now
really
yoked Chappelle man interesting choice
chelle's yoked huh dude Chappelle is I I
want to hear this Dan story but
Chappelle so I met the Dayton Funny Bone
one night and Chappelle has clearly been
working out and he walks in and I don't
recognize him I he I'm getting paid and
you know obviously to those you who
don't know but when you get paid it's a
very intimate moment it's you and the
general manager usually or you and the
manager no one's allowed in the room
they kick everyone out I'm getting paid
Chappelle walks in and I like whatever I
am I'm I am whatever I am I can't deny
it but like this is black dude walk in
in the middle I'm like who the [__]
this guy in the from the kitchen walking
into my I'm getting paid like I don't
I'm not thinking it's going to be Dave
Chapelle I just see a black dude walk in
and I'm the only black guys you see at
the Dayton Funny Bone or a lot of times
often are the guys in the kitchen and I
go cuz it's Flor I go what the [__] man
and I see a Chappelle it's like seeing a
great white shark and I've seen a great
white shark it is impressive I'm like oh
my God you d spell and he was like and
he just [__] cool as [__] yeah man
and was
so genuinely a comic yeah in like in
like and like he just was talking about
he's having a hard time writing material
man it's so [__] hard coming up
material you know what I mean like he
wasn't like I'm Dave Chappelle I have
millions of dollars I'm so much better
than you he was just one comic talking
to another comic and yeah you getting
paid I don't give a f like ultimately I
don't give a [__] whatever your [__]
five grand guarantee is does not a I'm
not impressed I don't care he was just a
comic talking to a comic and it was like
I was blown the [__] away yeah he's a
great guy D want hear the Dan story oh
oh right so so he is about to do a one
of the late night shows and he's running
his set yeah he does a joke and I'm like
well Tom rhods has that exact joke and
Tom rhs has done that joke on television
yeah so he might the guy on stage might
want to know that yeah because he's
about to do the same [__] joke so I'm
standing there and he gets off stage and
I go hey man just so you know Tom rhods
already did that exact joke on whatever
show at the time I go on the show and he
looks at me and he Pats me on the head
and he walks
out Jesus Dave you really are given a
couple stories tonight where all I can
see is smoke coming out of you I know I
mean Pat now ordinarily ordinarily I
would have [__] I would have [__]
decked him or the very least scre that
is I I don't know who side I'm on I mean
that is such I kind of want to give it
to D that is such that is such an
amazing move that is is so next level
that is [__] like it's putting the
Pat in patronizing he's patting you oh
my God oh my
God and he walked
out byebye see you later
R2D2 hey that he talks oh [__]
me oh my
god oh your face what he laugh I was so
stunned that I couldn't do anything oh
God that might be the new [__] move
that's how [__] crazy Dynamite it was
so [__] crazy done it that I was just
your wires were like crossed like
what R cook where is he God damn it he
just patted my head little r2d to his
head spin it around oh my God just a pat
me on the [__] head [__]
amazing I'll never forget it oh my God
yeah that that's why whenever people go
no Dane's all right I go no he's not you
know Dan Dane's a really interesting guy
um I knew him I knew him before uh
before I think all this bad stuff
happened in his life I think I I I'm not
certain I can't say this I don't really
hang out with Dane but like I think he's
a lot better but I but I than he was
like I remember one time I was like when
I was around him when we were younger it
was sometimes it was tough to be around
him because he was like you know was it
was like he was really hungry yeah he
was super hungry and uh and then and
then one day I saw him I hung out with
him it was when he got really famous and
uh and he just seemed very calm and I go
you seem you seem really grounded and he
was like well you know losing both your
parents and $13 million will do that to
you I was like I was like oh wow I
forgot I forgot you're a human also know
sometimes it's like and went through a
crazy experience even beyond that I mean
his like yeah I mean that you know
you're not nobody you there's really no
handbook on how to like handle a huge
rise quickly that then has sort of has
shows people's darker side it goes back
to what you were saying about like I I
would say I and subtract the
conversation about Dane out of this but
I like
like I bet it would have
been
different had he been 40 and all this
happened oh yeah you know man it's like
it's like people want to take down I
want to say it's like
America you know we were talking about
Creed yeah it's like there's something
wrong with America that we won't allow
things to be great like we want to take
down we want to take down anything the
first instinct is to hate it yeah and
and you know I'll be very honest
Dane I when I first watched Dane I was
like God damn it I need to do more of
that like that was amazing yeah it was
like watching a c man make fire I was
like how is he not bombing how is he not
bombing like I couldn't figure out's not
bombing and you know for a fact I know
we were both in the same circle at the
time that there were a lot of guys that
copied his style oh [__] yeah it was the
thing that was like the thing and I
would argue to say there are still guys
copying his style working today I agree
and totally and and Dane was the guy
that came out with that style like that
style of of the hands and the [__]
I'm driving I'm driving and like and I
dude I to this day the most hacky joke I
have I had a joke about um it was stolen
not stolen but the the I was like I had
a joke I didn't know how to write it the
me and Patrice were on a plane and uh
the flight attendant cut me
off and but she was stumbling on her
words to cut me off we're were flying to
Scotland I said can I get another beer
and she goes you know what actually sir
can I and I took my finger and I put it
to her lips and I went sh oh my God and
Patrice lost his [__] mind lost his
[__] mind and I and I tried to tell
it on stage in Scotland and he goes nah
the next morning we were sitting there
and he's like it doesn't work with a
stewardess cuz it doesn't matter yeah he
like you should make it a cop and I was
like okay so I tried telling it again
and it just didn't work and then I laid
in bed and I went and this you would say
whatever you want to say about me but I
went how would David tell tell the joke
and and my set up and punch for that
joke and you can find it online is uh
you know what cops hate when you touch
their faces is that not a tell it's a
tell it's a tell and then but then I
would I would I this is what a hack I
was is I went right to I moved to and I
had that setup punch and then I watched
Dane and I was like you know what you do
you know what you do you're driving down
the street when you're driving driveing
top comes up the window don't don't like
and I just stole from d right I stole
from both of them so that I could tell a
jokes I didn't know how to tell a joke
and you got to grow and figure out how
to tell a joke but I was like [__] it
man I got to I got to figure out this
business I don't know how to tell a joke
yeah but uh but that [__] there so
many people stole from that guy like
stole his Essence and I know that that's
you know what's funny if you watch Greg
if you watch Greg
Baron yeah danne stole Greg's Essence
wait can I tell you something I find for
sure yeah one I remember my wife had
never seen so we were good friends with
uh Greg and but my wife she'd seen Greg
a million times she'd never seen Dane
Cook and Dane Cook hosted C Night Live
and I was like let's just watch his
[__] monologue and he's doing it and
she looks at me and she goes he's
[__] doing Greg like this is Greg
Greg is a real original like meaning
like I I feel like when I watch Greg
it's really his voice yes and one of the
things that really bums me out I don't
know if Greg knows this or not but like
uh we had had a joke that I told him our
special that was very similar to one of
the ones he tells in a story that I love
the story it was about daughters I my
joke is um I have I have uh I have two
daughters Georgia 12 blonde hair blue
eyes real smart and I got another one oh
yeah and he's got a joke similar to that
but I already told him my special and so
when I heard his joke I went oh I have a
joke I already told it I was like well
there's no point in going up to him and
making it uncomfortable and going like
hey Greg I told a joke like that like
it's weird yeah but then we ended up
doing a show together in Montreal and I
told the joke and I had already heard
him tell the joke a number of times and
I did it in Montreal cuz I was bombing
or whatever and then I brought him on
stage and I went a and he looked gave me
this weird look and I was like oh I
would never steal but but it's so
similar yeah cuz he's got the same
relationship with his daughters I think
right but I I always felt guilty about
that I should probably talk to him about
it but I guess did we'll reach out and
hopefully he'll reply unlike some people
just send him this podcast how many how
how many hours in does he have to get
remember yeah remember the time code by
the way by the way by the
way this is uh this is a pretty epic
podcast what are we at uh right now I
think we're at
like 4 hours no no 3 Hour 3 hours and 30
minutes wow Jes that's crazy wow you
know by the way uh all that means to my
fans is this will get I'm just be real
cuz I'm drunk uh this will get a quarter
of a million downloads first
week okay that's great yeah that's all
right that's a big that's a big podcast
yeah and and by my my fans and they and
you'll see it in the thing they'll all
reply right now and they'll go he's
right like if it's if it's an hour they
[__] pass really really because why
cuz they know that you weren't having a
good time yeah a lot of times are like
that sort of goes to the point of what
you were saying before how this is your
your podcast is talking to people that
in like that's a barometer of uh you
interest me more than having sex with my
wife whoa that's weird
cuz I'm more into having sex with your
wife interesting that makes sense Pat
his head Pat his head bird Pat his head
and go
inside No it's it's this is uh this is
the sweet spot right now someone on my
podcast has hit pause and seen how much
more time we did and they've gotten
excited right this is like I'm telling
you when I say I know when I do good
podcast this is one of the better ones
I've ever done the one I did with Tommy
seura today was was pretty [__]
amazing um we called Bill Burr and Bill
was not happy about being put on the
podcast
immediately awesome that sounds pretty
good he was like go is this how the
business
Works dude bill is so a such a [__]
interesting guy I bring him I I invite
him over one night to one day to do a
podcast me him and Tom my 200th
episode I said we'll have cigars we have
some whiskey we'll have a good
time he comes over and he sees the mic
and I go I hit record and he goes the
[__] is this oh my God I go it's a
podcast you can hear it and he goes oh
so now we're just leveraging our
friendship for to exceed in this
business and I go no and I look at Tom I
go it was clear that this was going to
be a podcast right I like yeah yeah B's
like oh [__] so I guess we're doing a
podcast we're totally doing a
podcast but Bill's one of those guys
that will call you up and go like let's
hang out no microphones no nothing I
just need to be around people and you're
and you're and you have those great like
you know I I really say this honestly
but he like he's got one of those great
[__] minds yeah like a oh my God it's
like it's like unbelievable yeah it I
mean in The Limited times I've hung out
with him I am like wow your mind does
function in this way where it processes
things differently and it com dollop no
we talk we're yeah we he he's he wants
to come on we just haven't had a yeah
we're trying to figure out what you
think he's interested and and the
dollops one of them I think that from
listening to him on on Rogan and [__] I
mean I I definitely am like he I did a I
did one of the all things comedy
podcasts at uh The Comedy Store and Al
was sort of you know saying like what
the doll was and uh bill was like what's
one of the craziest things you ever like
you've said on there and I was like ah
there's and just randomly just blurted
out about the labotomy there was this
guy who the guy who came up with
labotomy it's this insane story but
eventually culture was so fine with
labotomy he was like putting on labotomy
shows and he had like a golden pick and
he drove a lmobile and Berling fla goes
shut the [__] up and I was like no that
is what it is and he was very interested
I was like come on man have you heard
him on the end of the world podcast
no amazing yeah okay there's two times
in my
life that I I would
say uh s like surrealness happened yeah
so like one time we did a goddamn Comedy
Jam at the Roxy and uh it's me and me
and it's a bunch of people me and bur on
the thing right and I'm I'm flying in
only to do the show and then I'm flying
back out on the red eyee so like I'm
just in for like five hours pops I've
been drink I I drink on planes so I I
land I go straight to the Roxy and Bill
Bill's warming up and then he goes hey
like uh let's go get a drink over the
rainbow room and I was like okay so we
go over to the rainbow room we get a
Jameson on the Rocks double Jameson on
the rocks and I me and Tom are going
through the fat shaming stuff and I we
and he goes uh looks like you're taking
on Water I said what and he goes I don't
know with this fat [__] it doesn't look
good doesn't look healthy like it seems
like you're taking on water and I go
yeah it's kind of bothering me and he
starts talking to me about shame like in
a very real French way uhhuh and I was
like man what he's saying right now is
so funny like right right and I want to
tell him go this should be in your act
but I don't say anything and then he
stops and he goes he like
he by the way no one share this with
Bill because this is a special moment
for me but he goes he goes I can't
believe I'm having drinks with the
machine and I and I and it really means
a lot to me then we go to the Roxy and
everything he just talked to me about he
does on stage and it [__] murders it
murders and I go I just witnessed that
like I witnessed that personally that
was a special moment I had I shouldn't
talk about it out loud that's [__]
brilliant [__] Destro and I'm like
are you [__] kidding me the machine
oh dude that is amazing it was the
greatest like it was the greatest little
small moment you have in your life where
you're like you know I don't know having
drinks with the machine I I when he was
on Marin so we were hang out all day and
we would just talk and like it's it's
hard to describe because we've hung
around with so many other Comics but
I've never seen someone in conversations
turn stuff everything into it's a
different perspective what's he just
turns everything into a brilliant bit
Yeah like he just in conversation he
finds the thing that is [__]
hilarious and the problem that you've
never thought of with it the ocean was a
fine thing it's just incredible and then
he talks about the ocean and you're like
the ocean is terrifying why have I not
been scared of the ocean the ocean is a
jungle that you can't see I mean that's
this joke he had and he said it and I
was like this is so
right it's insane dude he
is and and he doesn't like hearing this
but like one one of the better Minds I
know like I know some really great minds
I think we all do but like man his to
watch his work did you see him in um
Sarah Tiana get into it no the end of
the world sarahana I love sarahana She's
fantastic and she stands up for what she
believes in as do Morgan Murphy but man
they decided to argue with Bill Burr I
would not want to do that and I said to
them at the beginning why would you ever
argue with a guy whose whole Act is
based on looking at both sides of the
finding the most ridiculous point of
view and then arguing it
backwards I'll tell you
right man it did not turn out well for
Sarah Tiana oh man she so badly that I
tweeted her in that time and she's like
I guess you just think I'm a [__] or
something like that and I go what she
goes I don't know everyone's just
calling me a [__] I go I never said this
she goes well that's all I'm hearing
online CU you know obviously Army like
the the army of dudes that
identify with Bill yeah that look at
sier s Sierra Sarah for arguing with
Bill and are like how dare you right you
don't argue with the King God damn it
but
like and then and then Stan hope got it
on Bill's side oh there was a
moment it was like it was it was pretty
amazing to watch I do want to hear that
it was like being at it was like being
at like a coup's retreat and watching
two people fight and then Oprah jumping
in like it was so
f it was I'll tell you it was pretty
magical it was like one of the better
times that I was like I kept going don't
do this don't do this look at my head
but Sierra Sierra I keep saying Sierra
Sierra you're combining Sierra Tiana
into one Siana yeah she's CH she should
Chang her name all right I'm pretty
hammered we've done we've done that is
the best out I really am pretty drunk
I'm shocked that's great I started
drinking this morning at uh 9 cuz a fly
did you sleep right right no oh you
haven't slept had a cigar oh then that's
like having a nap I had I had a pizza so
I we got pizza oh no those are both like
having a nap yeah my well I got pizza
from me and my daughters and uh and I
have not eaten unhealthy at all except
last night with buns uh we had uh prime
rib uhuh but um I've been eating healthy
at all and I had definitely haven't had
pizza and I've been looking forward to
it yeah so I was like I've earned it
it's been over a month that I've been on
a diet I a piece of pizza and I choked
in the kitchen what all no yeah why such
a [__] [__] and and my daughters
were there and they you think because
you nervous about you guys yeah
no you think it's cuz we were coming
over yeah I think so it's okay berd you
can eat still hey bird hasn't eaten
since you guys left he won't eat but
what happened was I choked I took a bite
of pizza and then the cheese was like
super if you're not if you haven't done
it for a while and you're not used to it
it's [__] gnarly it really is this
sounds crazy to say but it's really hard
to eat pizza like I had a really hard
time getting it and I choked and my
daughter's in there I'm not even [__]
around I pulled pizza out of my throat
with my hand and and my daughter saw me
and then I was like and I was like I
can't believe this just [__] happened
and you and you guys are on your
way and I go uh I'm going to make myself
a really stiff cocktail so I made a 32 o
vodka soda yeah and I I was like I
freaked out and I haven't eaten because
of it cuz it really scared the [__] out
of me you had to rip pizza out of your
esophagus no you I pulled I pulled it
out of my throat it was crazy you once
you start eating healthy you realize how
[__] up everything when you try to go
back dude so I I I eat really healthy
now too and uh I took my kid down to uh
Santa Mona Pier this weekend and I was
[__] starving and I was like God I
should eaten before I got her this is
just all [__] and I'm like what do you
want he goes I want a hot dog so I get
him a hot dog and I order two and I'm
like all right and I put it in my mouth
and I bite it and I'm like oh my God
like just I was like this is the worst
cuz I haven't had anything like I've
just been eating super [__] healthy
for a couple of months yeah and I put
and I was like Jesus Christ this is
horrendous it's insane to me because I
part of me goes like I had that problem
last night I started choking last night
and I wonder I go wonder if my body is
like rejecting yes things that it
doesn't want because you know all I do
this diet that I did was super unhealthy
but all I did was I do a kale juice in
for uh breakfast I'd maybe do scrambled
eggs or like eggs eggs are cool with me
and then lean protein and greens and
vonka sodas but
like I have never choked like that
before ever like it was stuck in my
throat I had to reach down my with my
hand and my daughter saw it and they
were like my daughter after the fact
patted me on the back like are you okay
and I was like stop it daddy's not gross
anymore can I go back to walking in and
you and Mom doing it
please you think I st she's going to be
she's going to be in therapy first
question she's going to be in therapy
when she's 30 and then he pulled the
pizza out of his mouth dude it was I'm
not even [__] around it was a foot
long of string oh I had to pull it out
of my throat [__] and I'm and I'm
starving right now but I'm like I don't
know what I guess I'm I don't know I
talked to Dr Drew about it because I was
like I think I have anorexia I was
eating under a th000 calories which is
very very l oh that's ter yeah that's
not you're not supposed to do that yeah
well it was a bet and so was a bet a
great bet his kidney shut down it was a
great bet yeah it did a lot for my
career if you want to see my Google
Trends I'm
spiking that's great though by the way I
want to get rid of my podcast and just
to a podcast with you you guys this has
been the most seamless when you guys go
to Australia can I open for you yes I
can help s tickets I can help sell some
tickets like right like I'm sure I got a
few fans in Australia probably exact
fans you guys have probably
identical anyone that is a fan of mine
is probably already a fan of your guys
don't touch bird he riddled with disease
oh all right I'm going to let you guys
go this has been well thank you so much
man honestly thank you for plugging the
podcast thank you for having us on you
guys do I likewise dude truly so I
really do think it's great and I'm I'm
and You're Going to Be Our Guest and our
the one we're going to do it uh oh yeah
yeah February February 6 February 6 yeah
February 6th let me put my calendar but
uh um God damn it I am hammered what was
I going to say we are great yeah you
some about
fantastic thing I love about all things
comedy truly I'm being serious when I
say that uh is you know when Allan Bill
started this and and asked us to all
come aboard and and I didn't understand
the the value of it yeah and I and I
think we can all still say that we no
one really has a value to
it you know there's no technical value
to All Things comedy but the cool thing
is is this is like is like that we do
that meeting this and the things we're
about to do it's going to be [__]
cool I what I like what we're going to
do I like where we're going with this um
and I just I think and and I'll say this
real quick uh I know I don't I'm not
sure who everyone's a part of this but
there's an app called laughable if you
guys don't use it use it you you don't
know about it it's so great um what it
does is you get the app and then you
type in the person you like and then it
shows you all the shows they've ever
been on oh wow and so like I'm a big
Rory Scoville fan love Rory oh yeah like
to the point where I say he might be the
best comic working right now with like
that kind of guy just different
and everything he does is [__]
amazing and if you type in Rory Scoville
on laughable you find out all the [__]
he's been on and you go holy like how
great is that like I that's how I found
out I did 20 Rogan is I was like oh [__]
wow so check out the laughable app uh
for you guys but more importantly like I
would say anything you guys have ever
been on independently together dude I'll
be [__] hardcore going through that
this week you got than [__] funny man
I thank you very much for being on the
podcast thank you for having for having
us man yes truly I love you guys I love
you bird I'm going to blow you
now tell
[Music]
BR this episode was brought to you by
the
machine